Jetzt sagt die Frau das noch mal, ne?
Frank!
Mist!
Wieder, ich bin zu doof hier, irgendwie was zu bedienen. Hier ist das Chaosradio, wie man hört.
Ich nicht san chi.
Ich nicht san si.
Hey, lange nicht gehört.
Na Holger?
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend, hier ist es Chaosradio 65.
Was haben wir denn da für ein Film?
Maman, Fernseher aus, wir machen hier Radio.
Prozervierische Bilder sind jetzt gerade ein bisschen...
Ja und das gilt auch für alle anderen und auch deinem Freund. Chaosradio 65 im Studio Frank, Andreas und... Andreas, das geht nicht.
Nein, ich heiße nicht Andreas, ich heiße Andi.
Ach so, entschuldigung, darf ich mal deinen Ausweis sehen?
Ja.
Ist da ein Fingerabdruck drin?
Nein.
Warum nicht?
Ähm, weil ganz soweit ist es ja zum Glück. Ach komm, nicht?
Wie? Nicht? Nee, lebensart. Was machen wir denn heute?
Wir reden heute über Terror und Freiheit, aber erstmal dachten wir, reden wir darüber, was wir die letzten paar Wochen gemacht haben. Nein, wir waren nicht in New York.
Behauptet zumindest Andi.
Aber du bist schon öfter in New York Andi, ne?
Ich bin an dem Dienstag gerade aus Montevideo wiedergekommen. Aber eigentlich hatten wir uns für den Dienst da fast ganz schönes vorgenommen, nämlich unsere Fosteröffnung.
Ja, wir hatten 20 Jahre Chaos Computer Club und dazu gab es eine Ausstellung am Alexanderplatz in der Kongresshalle. Und weil wir ja kreative Menschen sind, haben wir beschlossen, wir können auch sinnvolle Dinge mit Hochhäusern anstellen und haben eine Kunstinstallation gemacht und da gibt es jetzt ein 8x18 Pixel großes Display.
Ich bin an dem Dienstag gerade aus Montevideo wiedergekommen. Sicher?
Ich.
Bin an dem Dienstag gerade aus Montevideo wiedergekommen.
Sicher?
Sicher? Ich bin an dem Dienstag gerade aus Montevideo wiedergekommen. Ich bin an dem Dienstag gerade aus Montevideo wiedergekommen.
Ich bin an dem Dienstag gerade aus Montevideo wiedergekommen. Ich bin an dem Dienstag gerade aus Montevideo wiedergekommen. Ich bin an dem Dienstag gerade aus Montevideo wiedergekommen. Sicher? Sicher?
Ich bin an dem Dienstag gerade aus Montevideo wiedergekommen. Sicher? Sicher? Ich bin an dem Dienstag gerade aus Montevideo wiedergekommen. Sicher? Kommt doch jetzt gleich.
Kommt jetzt gleich? Ja, das kommt jetzt gleich.
Entschuldigung, da leuchten schon so rote Nampen, ich glaube die hören uns schon.
Die hören uns schon. Nee, keine Angst hat keiner gehört.
Zu hören statt abhören.
Also das war übrigens gerade ein Bibelzitat aus dem Alten Testament.
Also ein Teil der Musik, die wir heute spielen, die stand von einer interessanten Liste und zwar ist die Liste der Songs, die von einer der größten amerikanischen Radioketten nach den Anschlägen in New York als offensiv oder offending markiert wurde. Das heißt also, die Herrenredakteure wurden halt gebeten, diese Songs nicht zu spielen, weil man doch irgendwie da Bedenken hatte, dass irgendjemand sich auf den Schlips getreten fühle, wenn man solche Musik spielt und da dachten wir, bringen wir diese Musik doch mal ein bisschen zugehören, mal diese ganze Absurdität dieses Medientheaters, die da gerade stattfindet, ein bisschen deutlicher zu machen.
Gebeten von wem?
Na von den Leuten, die diese Radiosender gehören.
Im Moment gab es noch diese Vorauseilende, diese Clear Channel.
Das ist so ein Radioverbund.
Das ist genau so ein Radioverbund.
Das heißt, es ist so ein vorauseilender Gehorsam gewesen.
Genau so.
Das ist jetzt halt bad, zum Beispiel von ACDC Safe in New York City, das will man jetzt gerade nicht hören, aber selbst so harmlose Sachen wie Imagine.
John Lennon ist gerade verboten. Alles.
Ja, wir wollten sozusagen, bevor wir dann zum eigentlichen Thema kommen, nämlich welche Auswirkungen die jetzige Situation so ein bisschen auf die Situation der Netzbewohner haben wird, könnte. Ein bisschen mal über das Medienereignis reden. Es gab da ja zum Beispiel ganz am Anfang vielleicht diejenigen, die früh am Fernseher saßen, erinnern sich, da war von einer Autobombe beim State Department die Rede.
Ja, das war die dritte Meldung. Also erstes Flugzeug, zweites Flugzeug, Autobombe und dann sind die Dinge erst eingeschlafen.
Die Autobombe, die gab es dann die nächste Woche schon nicht mehr.
Interessanterweise gab es aber ungefähr zu der Zeit, wo die Autobombe gemeldet wurde, einen kleinen Peak auf dem Sathmogramm, was später veröffentlicht wurde, wo man den Einschlag der Flugzeuge und die Einstürze in Hochhäuser genau gesehen hat. Da gab es halt so einen kleinen Peak, der wurde halt nicht erklärt.
Das heißt, die Autobombe hat stattgefunden, aber wurde nicht mehr erwähnt?
Also wie so viele Dinge, die stattgefunden haben und dann gerade nicht mehr erwähnt werden.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass CNN zumindest es ja dann doch ein bisschen der dominante Sender war von der Abteilung, wie heißt das noch schnell? Psychological Operations? Der National Security Agency.
Achso, Radio Andernach, ja.
Nee, nee, es gab irgendwie im Zuge dieser Geschichten, kam halt hoch, dass schon seit dem Beginn des Kosovo-Konfliktes bei CNN und anderen großen Medienorganisationen Offiziere von der US Army, von der Division for Psychological Operations als Interns, also als Praktikanten, arbeiteten. Und es wurde dann halt berichtet, naja, es sind heute 40 Jahre...
Macht Känze Buscheue nicht gerade ein Praktikum in Amerika?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Jedenfalls scheint da die Medienkontrolle einigermaßen dreckig stattzufinden. Und wenn ich mir so angucke, was man so auf CNN sieht, dann, naja, mir fühlt man sich doch so ein bisschen an aktuelle Kamera früher erinnert, weil man hört immer so dieselben Bilder, dieselben Reden und so weiter und so fort. Und richtig schlimm wird's, wenn man dann mal so irgendwie so ein paar Filme guckt. Also wir haben in den letzten Tagen mal intensiver so ein paar Filme geguckt, zum Beispiel gibt's da diesen schönen Film The Siege, zur deutschen Ausnahmezustand mit Bruce Willis als bösem General. Und ich hab's leider nicht geschafft, das Audio-Sample irgendwie rauszusuchen, aber es ist doch sehr interessant zu sehen, dass die Rede von Bush, die er da gehalten hat, so von wegen, make no mistake, we got a job to do no matter what the price, sind wortwörtliche Zitate aus der Ansprache, die Bruce Willis da als General gehalten hat, als er da in New York war. Genau, so, also es ist halt irgendwie schon doch irgendwie deutlich zu sehen, dass irgendwie das, was man da so im Fernsehen sieht, halt irgendwie eine sehr sorgfältige Inszenierung ist, die halt irgendwie auch irgendwie vor ziemlich fragwürdigen Parallelen nicht so richtig zurückschrecken.
Und dann war da noch die Sache mit der Düngemittelfabrik.
Team Toulouse, genau. Team Toulouse.
Also nebenbei im Hintergrund hören wir jetzt gerade pakistanische...
Soul Music.
Nur wir haben uns überlegt, dass wir uns auf die Talibanisierung Europa schon mal ein bisschen einstimmen. Und natürlich die Hörer mit.
Also das ist jetzt gerade Papu und Jora sein mit D'Hool.
Ja, genau. Das hab ich mir gerade von meinem ehemaligen Lieblingsterroristen sozusagen noch ausgeborgt. Es gibt halt im Moment ein paar Ereignisse, wo man sich die vorstellen könnte, ob die in Zusammenhang stehen. Darüber lieber gar nicht reden.
Ach komm.
Naja, ich heile gut. Man kann sich auf der Basis der Ereignisse, die stattgefunden haben, jede Menge Theorien zurechtspinnen. Was man wohl einigermaßen ausschließen kann, angesichts der Dimension des Anschlages, ist, dass es die amerikanischen Dienste selber waren. Dann gibt es natürlich noch die Gerüchte darüber, dass es die Israelis waren, oder dass zumindest die Israelis davon wussten. Und dann gibt es irgendwie komische Geschichten von irgendwelchen Leuten an Hochhäusern, die angeblich nicht zur Arbeit gekommen sind und israelische Staatsbürger waren, die sich dann aber nicht besonders angehalten haben.
Ja, aber Frank, wie erklärst du dir, dass am Flughafen von Boston ein weißes Fahrzeug hinterlassen wird mit einem arabisch beschrifteten Flugplan, mit einem arabischen Lehrvideo für das Fliegen von Verkehrsmaschinen und einem Koran? Und der Zettel fehlte mit freundlichen Grüßen von Bin Laden. Also wo ist der Zettel geblieben?
Ich hätte da eine Theorie, wie es dazu kommt. Da hat also einer tatsächlich ein Auto abgestellt mit einem Flugplan drin. Was war das noch? Eine Bedienungsanleitung?
Ne, so ein Lehrvideo.
Also so kam das dann vermutlich mal. Also ich vermute, das hat da einer hingestellt.
Weil der Koran ist da zugedichtet, meinst du, oder?
Weiß ich nicht, aber...
Du meinst also, wer war das deiner Meinung nach?
Nein, ich fand das nur, also ich hab das ja auch nur so als Medienereignis alles, sozusagen wahrgenommen. Und als ich das in der Zeitung gelesen hab, da hab ich mir überlegt, also wenn ich jetzt einen Film gucken würde, und es käme also zu dieser Szene mit den Hochhäuser, würde ich schon sagen, also das ist ein bisschen an den Haaren herbeigezogen. Aber dann die Sache mit dem Auto und dem Koran und so, da würde ich sagen, also dieser Film ist mir zu billig, da hätte ich irgendwie umgeschaltet.
Ja, stimmt, die Auflösung kam zu früh.
Oder hat den Video zurückgegeben, oder irgendwann, das wäre mir ein bisschen zu schlicht.
Ja, aber du darfst nicht vergessen, dass die Amerikaner ein bisschen schlicht sind. Ich meine, wenn du halt irgendwie, wenn sie dann nicht mehr merken, dass sie da irgendwie Bruce Willis Zitate von ihrem Präsidenten vorgelesen bekommen, das ist schon ganz schön hart.
Naja, aber die haben ja auch bei dem Benefits-Konzert denselben Musiker, der bei Wack the Dog diesen Song da spielt, wo man dann einen virtuell erfunden hat. Also Wack the Dog ist ein Film über sozusagen Medienmanipulation, der grobe Plot besteht darin, dass der Präsident sich mit einer 14-Jährigen eingelassen hat und das droht, rauszukommen, und er entsprechend eine Menge Ärger gegen sich aufkommen sieht. Und er entzündet dann kurz einen Weltkrieg oder vielmehr einen kriegerischen Konflikt in der Golfregion, um eben davon abzulenken, dass er gerade wegen sexueller Belastung einer 14-Jährigen. Und im Rahmen dieses Films inszeniert er halt zu zahlen dieses Medienerhebnis und engagiert da professionell Leute, die dann eben ein Drama erzeugen mit einem Kind, was gerettet wird und einem Soldaten, der verloren geht. Und der Soldat heißt Schumann. Und da wird also ein Song gemacht, ihm zu ehren und bla bla bla. Und derselbe Musiker, der in diesem Film Wake the Dog wie gesagt diese Rolle spielt als engagierter Komponist, diese Sache zu dramatisieren, der war jetzt auch bei dem Benefits-Konzert für die Opfer von New York. Also maßgeblich hat er da rumgesessen mit seiner Gitarre. Und es ist immer schwerer zu unterscheiden zwischen Funktion und Realität. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das was mit dem Internet zu tun hat. Ich glaube, das geht auch so.
Ja, ich glaube, wenn es Internet nicht gäbe, würde es noch viel schlimmer sein, weil dann gäbe es ja nur noch Fernsehen.
Dann lieber Lothish. Also was in dem ganzen Zusammenhang einfach nochmal erwähnenswert ist, ist vielleicht, dass auch alles was jetzt passiert, einfach einer starken Filterung unterliegt und man kann dafür Verständnis haben oder nicht, aber man sollte sich dessen zumindest bewusst sein. Wir hatten ja zum Beispiel gerade in Frankreich die Explosion einer Düngemittelfabrik durch, ja, wodurch auch immer.
Es ist eigentlich egal, wodurch das Ding explodiert ist.
Das ist wenn es hat man kein Flugzeugflügel mehr gesehen, da der heraus ragt.
Ich meine selbst wenn der heraus ragt hätte, wäre es irgendwie schlau gewesen von den Franzosen das Ding als Unfall zu deklarieren. Die haben immerhin eine nicht ganz unerhebliche muslimische Bevölkerung, die teilweise auch nicht besonders reich ist und teilweise auch schon ziemlich radikalisiert ist. Und insofern kann man schon durchaus nachvollziehen, dass sie nicht unbedingt irgendwie da gerade noch den irgendwie brodelnden Rassenkonflikt im eigenen Land haben wollen, der auf einer Straße ausgetragen wird insofern.
Und wie war noch gleich die Erklärung der Bundesbahn für den gestern fast entgleisten ICE?
Ich weiß nicht genau, also im Zug haben sie gesagt, dass es irgendwie ein Anschlag gewesen sein soll und draußen haben sie dann gesagt, das war wohl ein Unfall.
Als wegen wäre der beinahe entgleist?
Ein Stück Schiene, da steckte wohl ein Stück Schiene einigermaßen schräg im Gleis oder so ähnlich.
Eine Schiene, die sich quer zur Fahrtrichtung über den eigentlichen Gleisen befand und immerhin ein Gewicht von...
Die ist vom Laster gefallen wahrscheinlich.
Ist irgendwie vom Winter hingewied oder irgendetwas.
Und wenn ein Güterzug, der dem entgegen gekommen ist, hat eine Schiene verloren, die dann rechtwinklig zur Fahrstrecke auf dem Ding lag und das war ein Unfall. Ja, ich mein, hey!
Aber ich mein, es gab halt ja auch, als das Flugzeug in den Südturm stürzte, gab es auch Berichte über eine Explosion unten im Gebäude.
Es gab auch ein Bericht über eine Chessner, die in den Turm geflogen wäre, die nie wieder aufgetaucht ist.
Naja, das waren aber die, ich meine, das sind ja insgesamt am Anfang.
Beim ersten wussten sie gar nichts, da haben sie auch von einem Hubschrauber geredet und alles Mögliche.
Also wenn du alle Flugzeugbezeichnungen zusammennimmst, die die da irgendwie alleine am Dienstag gesagt haben, dann sind da glaube ich acht Maschinen reingerauscht oder sowas. Also ja, irgendwie mindestens eine 747, eine 75 und eine 767. Also, alles mit der Schiene finde ich interessant.
Ja, gut, aber...
Was willst du was?
Äh, einiges.
Was geht da?
Ich such das mal raus, ich hab diese Mail hier irgendwo bei mir rumliegen.
Suchs mal raus.
Jetzt sagen wir noch kurz was zum Stand der Propaganda.
Das ist übrigens Chaosradio, ja? Für den Fall ist es 65. 65, genau.
Mir ist irgendwie beim Suchen im Netz ein Song untergekommen, den wir nicht vorenthalten wollen. Es ist offenbar ein amerikanischen Propaganda-Song, der dann wohl auch auf etlichen Militärinstallationen der Amerikaner rings um die Welt gespielt wurde, so morgens zum Aufwachen und der heißt Mr. Taliban. Der ist gelaufen, über den Lautsprecher und so.
Wenn Franz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2, 22, 30.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Heute Nacht Stellenweise Nebel, Abkühlung auf 9 bis 7 Grad, morgen dann Bewölkung und die nimmt auch noch zu im Norden, also wenn man auf die Karte guckt oben in Brandenburg, da gibt es dann als erstes Regen, das Ganze bei 18 Grad, und es gibt Meldungen mit gesiebenen Kühen.
Bundeskanzler Schröder hat am Abend die Ministerpräsidenten der Länder empfangen, um mit ihnen über die Lage nach den Terroranschlägen in den USA zu beraten. Zu der Unterredung waren auch die Präsidenten des Bundeskriminalamtes, des Bundesnachrichtendienstes und des Bundesamts für Verfassungsschutz geladen. Mehrere Friedens- und Literaturnobelpreisträger haben sich gegen einen Krieg in Afghanistan ausgesprochen. Im ARD-Magazin Monitor warnten sie vor einer Spirale der Gewalt. Zu Wort meldeten sich unter anderem der südafrikanische Bischof Desmond Tutu, der Schriftsteller Günter Grass und der Theaterregisseur Dario Faux. Das UNO-Flüchtlingshilfswerk hat dazu aufgerufen, ein Notprogramm für Flüchtlinge aus Afghanistan aufzulegen. Es soll einen Umfang von mehr als 250 Millionen Dollar haben. Das deutsche Entwicklungsministerium stellte 15 Millionen Mark als Soforthilfe bereit. Die NATO hat heute eine Nachfolgemission für Mazedonien beschlossen. Unter deutscher Führung will das Bündnis nun Soldaten zum Schutz von etwa 200 zivilen Beobachtern von EU und OSZE nach Mazedonien entsenden. Die geplante Fusion von vier Energieunternehmen zum drittgrößten deutschen Stromkonzern ist gescheitert. Der schwedische Vattenfall-Konzern und die US-Gruppe Myron konnten sich nicht auf die Zusammenlegung der Firmen Bevak, Haif, Vee, Werk und Lauvak einigen.
Vielen Dank, Gesine, 22 Uhr, 32.
Am 13.
Mein Name ist Sammy Deluxe und unterwegs mit der Feiertour. Leiden nur 20 Tage, doch der Shit raubt pur.
McKay-Z und Black Twang, also check sense on me.
Mit dem neuen Rapslang am 13. besser hingehen, denn wir die Mikes nehmen, ja.
Fritz präsentiert Sammy Deluxe. Sammy Deluxe, Casey Daruki und Black Twang live in Berlin. Samstag, 13. Oktober in der Kolumbiale und im Radius.
Chaosradio 65 mit Soul Music aus Pakistan. Also steht auf jeden Fall auf der CD Pakistani Soul Music. Dürfen ihr, das klingt nach Popmusik, das hören die da gar nicht mehr, oder?
Nee doch, also wie mir gesagt wurde, es gibt da zwei Arten von Musiken. Das eine ist ungefähr das hier und dann gibt es noch, das hab ich leider nicht dabei, ich hab ein paar Webseiten, wo ich das hätte runter, da müssen aber eure Internet ist ja scheiße. Es gibt da so eine Art Heavy Metal Variante. Allerdings haben die halt nicht diese elektronischen oder elektrischen Gitarren, sondern die machen das eben auf ihre, wie soll ich sagen, mit ihren analogen Geräten.
Wie das so deren Art ist.
Vielleicht kriegen wir im Laufe der Sende noch das Internet hier mal zum Funktionieren.
So ein bisschen Netz hab ich schon, also wenn du überall das kannst, kann ich's downloaden.
Das Internet ist wie ein bisschen schwanger, oder?
afghanennetwork.net und dann gehen wir auf afghanennetwork.net Gib mir doch mal den Zettel. Ja, das kannst du eh nicht lesen, du hast meine Sauklaue.
Auch noch auf Arabisch.
Arabisch oder Kalibanesisch. Einfach www.afghannetwork.net und da gibt es unten so Dings zu Media-Dingern.
Okay, finde ich. Was hat da für die GEMA dazu, wenn Musikleifers im Internet spielen, im Radio?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Geh mal weg. So. Habt ihr nicht noch ein Thema?
Genau, du wolltest über den großen Plott reden.
Wir sollen uns ja im Laufe der Sendung an das annähern, was an amerikanischen und europäischen Vorstellungen formuliert wurde, um jetzt unter den Deckmantel der Terrorismusbekämpfung dieses und jenes zu tun. Aber vielleicht...
Diesen und jemen?
Diesen und jemen... Jetzt ist Frank natürlich im Cyberspace gelandet.
Vielleicht sortierst du und sammelst dich, während wir noch eine kleine Musik hören von der Liste dieser Lieder, die in Amerika derzeit nicht im Radio gespielt werden dürfen.
Auch eins mit Lokalbezug haben wir hier.
Ja, wunderbar. Tu mal rein jetzt.
Mach mal einen Klick.
Interessante Version, ist Chaosradio 65 auf Fritzi übrigens. Das war, von wem ist das Lied, Andreas?
Von REM.
Von REM war die Version, ahja. Ich kenn das ja in der Version von Leonard Cohen.
Na, so ein bisschen harmloser.
Ja, ist so netter freundlicher, so für den Abend so ein bisschen.
Wo der Text genauso subversiv ist.
Ja, allerdings.
Gut, wir wollten uns ein bisschen dem Plot widmen.
Dem Plot, was ist denn eigentlich passiert und warum?
Genau.
Für's Warum bist du zuständig, Anni, oder?
Na, ich meine, die Amerikaner, die fragen sich ja, wie ist dieses Hochhaus eingestürzt? Wie sind die Leute da an Bord gekommen? Wobei, ich hab gestern jemand getroffen, in einer Konferenz in Bonn. Der kam gerade aus Washington und da sagte er mir, er wäre leicht irritiert gewesen, ob der Sicherheitskontrolle. Sie hätten ihn immerhin gefragt, ob er ein Messer oder einen spitzen Gegenstand dabei gehabt hat. Hat er gesagt nein und dann haben sie ihn ins Flugzeug gelassen.
Oder eine Banane.
Sie haben nicht mit einem Metalldetektor kontrolliert. Sie haben es auch bei den anderen Passagieren nicht getan. Und er fand das scheiße.
Ja, Gesine, unsere Nachtredakteurin, sagt auch, genauso ist es ihr gegangen. Und heute Nachmittag habe ich im Fernsehen eingesehen, haben sie am Tegel Umfrage gemacht, wie das denn so mit den Sicherheitskontrollen ist, was man so über sich hier gehen lässt. Und da kam auch gerade einer aus dem Urlaub zurück und der meinte, komm, wir haben aus Spanien, die machen ja ja nichts, die winken einfach durch.
Na gut, aber das ist nicht der große Plot, es gibt da viermaligen CIA Agenten bin Laden.
Na gut, ich weiß nicht, ob er wirklich ein CIA Agent war, aber er hat immerhin die Ausbildung und die Kohle von hingewickelt.
Ich dachte, CIA Agenten heißen immer Johnson.
Na vielleicht hat er ja auch den Backname Johnson gemacht. Also ich denke, wir sehen da halt so ein Muster, also ohne das verharmlosen zu wollen, was da passiert ist in New York, ist es halt schon so, dass irgendwie die Amerikaner da so ein gewisses Pattern haben, dass sie halt immer wieder irgendwelche Leute dafür bezahlen, dass sie ihre dreckige Wäsche in einem Teil der Welt waschen und 15 Jahre später haben sie Ärger mit den Jungs. Das hat sich bisher irgendwie einigermaßen klar durchgezogen. Mit Neujäger war das genauso und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Insofern kann man da schon sagen, naja, sie haben da irgendwie eine gewisse Vorliebe dafür, sich Probleme selber zu mahnen. Was man natürlich sehen muss, ist, es gibt halt einfach da draußen jede Menge durchgeknallte Leute, die halt irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob sie Spaß daran haben, zumindest als ihre Berufung betrachten, halt irgendwie andere Leute mit in den Tod zu nehmen.
Du meinst jetzt aber gerade nicht die amerikanische Medienindustrie, sondern die anderen, ne?
Ich meine jetzt gerade die anderen, ja, genau. Wie die Amerikaner immer so schon sagen, towelheads, also die Leute mit den Handtüchern am den Kopf. Das ist so der normale amerikanische Mensch.
Jeder sollte doch wissen, wo er sein Handtuch hat, oder?
Genau. Also insofern ist es halt eine einigermaßen komplexe Menge Lage, die wir da gerade sehen. Also wir sehen halt, dass die Amerikaner halt natürlich versuchen, ihre Rache oder wie auch immer man es nennen mag, irgendwie durchzuziehen. Es gibt halt irgendwie da offenbar die Bereitschaft, in relativ großem Umfang Zugeständnisse zu machen, und mit Leuten zusammen zu arbeiten, mit denen man vorher nicht zusammen gearbeitet hat. Welche Folgen es dann hat, wird man dann in 15 Jahren sehen, inwieweit dann die Nordallianz irgendwie Führer plötzlich irgendwie anfangen, irgendwie was auch immer dann zu tun.
Schurken zu sein.
Genau, schurken zu sein. Also sie versuchen halt sozusagen Probleme dadurch zu lösen, dass sie Probleme in die Zukunft vertragen. Was halt passiert im Inland ist halt, dass die Leute natürlich alle in Panik sind und dass jetzt gerade die Zeit ist, bei der viele Leute denken, dass sie Gesetze durchpeitschen können, die sonst in normalen Zeiten nicht durchgegangen wären.
Na ja, gut. Ich meine, da haben wir jetzt ein paar, wo man muss noch mal ganz kurz auf den Plot vielleicht eingehen, um diese gesetzlichen Forderungen auch zu verstehen. Was da passiert ist, ist ja eben nicht, dass ein klar definiertes Land, ob das jetzt Afghanistan, Pakistan oder was auch immer ist, diesen Angriff gestartet hat. Und die Amerikaner haben ja auch in gewissem Sinne gezögert oder zögern noch, da irgendetwas zu tun, weil sie einfach nicht genau wissen, wo sie draufhauen sollen. Weil das halt eine sehr dezentrale Aktion ist, wenn man die so nennt. Und diese Schläfernetzwerke, das heißt Leute, die ausgebildet sind, die bezahlt werden, aber eben bezahlt dafür werden, ein ziviles Leben zu führen. Diese Schläfern, die gibt es, da gibt es eine lange Historie, auch in Europa. Es gab beispielsweise von den Westdiensten, also von den NATO-Ländern das sogenannte Gladionetzwerk, das theoretisch tatsächlich ausgebildet war, sollte ein oder mehrere europäische Länder in die Hände der Russen fallen, auch in Zeiten des Kalten Krieges, dass man dann eben Leute hat, die mit Sprengstoffen umgehen können, die Sabotage machen können, die auch Leute umbringen können, die irgendwie Trinkwasser versorgen und alles Mögliche platt machen können, damit eben diejenigen, die das Land einnehmen, da keine Freude dran haben. Die DDR hatte genau dasselbe, da hieß es nicht Gladionetzwerk, sondern die Arbeitsgruppe des Ministers für Sonderfragen in zwei Abteilungen nochmal, in der A und in der B. Die haben ähnlich leckere Sachen gelernt und sind dann eben im Westen stationiert gewesen, also Leute, die ebenfalls ein ganz normales ziviles, bürgerliches Leben hatten und ab und zu mal irgendwo Urlaub gemacht haben und dort sich eben wieder eine Abteilung Ausbildung zugelegt haben und so weiter und so fort. Und gut, abgesehen davon, dass übrigens diese Leute auch alle noch frei rumlaufen, weil das Problem ist ja, so Schläfernetzwerke, die kann man, auch wenn man den ganzen Staat auflöst, man kann ja die Leute nicht mit auflösen. Also die sind da auch noch da und die arbeiten dann im Service für den, der bezahlt. Es gab ja hier auch Gerüchte, dass beispielsweise bei der Biowaffenschulung eben Leute der Staatssicherheit aufgetaucht sind und so fort. Da kann man sich jetzt vielleicht, wenn man will, in den einstiegenden Suchmaschinen mit beschäftigen. Aber was jetzt interessant ist, ist natürlich die Frage, was tut man jetzt dagegen? Nehmen wir mal an, eine Gesellschaft will sich schützen. Und es sind jetzt halt zwei Maßnahmenkataloge oder vielmehr drei, kann man sagen, eigentlich schon vorgelegt worden. Die Europäische Kommission hat am Freitag zwei Papiere vorgelegt, einmal ein Combating Terrorism und das andere ist die Randparameter für einen europäischen Haftbefehl, wenn ich mich recht im Sinne.
Und eine europäische Definition für Terrorismus.
Und das andere Papier, die Amerikaner haben ebenfalls einen Maßnahmenkatalog vorgelegt, Draft of Department of Justice Surveillance and Anti-Terrorism Bill. Also da wird der Anti-Terrorismus gleich mit dem Begriff Überwachung gekoppelt. Also das heißt, es geht jetzt eigentlich in die Richtung, die natürlich viele schon befürchtet haben, dass das ganze mit dem Internet könnte ja auch in einem Überwachungsstaat ausarbeiten, ausarten vielmehr und jetzt ist natürlich die Begründung da, um zumindest eine Zeit lang so ungefähr jede Maßnahme durch ungefähr jedes Parlament genehmigt zu kommen. Und das ist eigentlich das, worüber wir uns mit euch auch unterhalten wollen.
Ja, wir wollen gerne auch...
Also mit euch da draußen so.
Wir wollen nämlich gerne mal wissen, was denkt ihr, was wären tatsächlich irgendwie Maßnahmen, die man als sinnvoll betrachten kann. Auch durchaus irgendwie, was wird ihr bereit an Maßnahmen zu erdulden. Und dann würden wir auch gerne auch mal im Detail darüber über die Sinnhaftigkeit von diesen Dingen diskutieren.
Tja, und die Nummer unter der ihr das tun könnt, das ist die hier.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Ich würde dann sonst... Ich hab hier dieses Papier, dieses europäische Papier, würde ich vielleicht dem geneigten Hörer noch die eine oder andere Sache, die jetzt also abgesehen von so einer schwarfligen Einleitung da drinnen stehen. Interessant ist natürlich, dass der Angriff auf zum Beispiel destroying political, economic, social structures, bla bla bla, also der Angriff auf technische Kommunikationsstrukturen, sprich das Internet, ist hier immer gleich mit drin. Allerdings sind auch, this could include for instance acts of urban surveillance, das heißt auch städtische Gewalt. Wir sagen, wenn... Und dann hab ich mich versprochen, ich meinte acts of urban violence, also das heißt auch wenn in Genua oder in anderen Städten, wo ja gegen die sogenannte Globalisierung demonstriert wurde, da eben mal im Straßen, keine Ahnung, Larm gelegt werden oder halt mal ein paar Autos umgekippt werden oder was auch immer. Auch das könnte dann unter diese Terrorismusdefinition fallen, die hier sozial neu gezogen wird und dann eben entsprechend nach sich ziehen, dass die Leute mindestens gleich mal ins Gefängnis gehen und ihre DNA abgeben müssen und. Das ist also die eine Sache, die an diesem Maßnahmenkatalog uns ein bisschen bedenklich stimmt. Zum anderen übrigens das ganze Dokument gibt es auf www.statewatch, also statewatch.org. Was interessant ist, ist, dass in Zukunft auch Unternehmen für die Handlung ihrer Angestellten haftbar gemacht werden sollen.
Da kann man schön Schabern akkunden.
Ja, aber das heißt zum Beispiel, dass im Zweifelsfall dieser Radiosender, so Redakteure wie dich, dann nochmal beim Verfassungsschutz oder beim Bundesnachrichtendienst überprüfen lassen muss, bevor er dich ans Mikrofon lässt, also der Sender, weil mich der ansonsten dafür mitverantwortlich ist, wenn du hier irgendwie talibanesische Musik spielst oder ähnliche Dinge tust, was du ja niemals tun würdest.
Hier steht ja Pakistani. Wie viele eurer Freiheiten wärt ihr bereit aufzugeben, um den Terror, den Chaos zu machen?
Wenn er nicht anreizt, lese ich weiter die Liste vor der Gesetze.
Erst mal im Mund, welche Freiheiten wärt ihr bereit aufzugeben, wenn ihr überhaupt welche aufgeben würdet und warum?
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Das klingt aber unangenehm, Andi.
Guten Abend, Daniel.
Daniel?
Daniel? Kannst du mich jetzt hören, Daniel? Daniel? Das Leben ist manchmal wirklich hart, dann nur ein bisschen Musik. Chaosradio 65 auf Fritz mit Musik aus Pakistan. Wie war noch gleich die Frage, Frank?
Genau, wir wollen eigentlich gerne mit euch darüber sprechen, was für Maßnahmen ihr bereit werdet zu erdulden oder was ihr denkt, was irgendwie sinnvoll wäre, um sich irgendwie zukünftig Versäuchen und ähnlichen Anschlägen zu schützen und was ihr denkt, was irgendwie tatsächlich jetzt irgendwie angemessenes handeln wäre.
Und die Nummer unter dir, die ihr äußern könnt, ist die hier.
0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
So und jetzt versuchen wir nochmal mit Daniel zu sprechen. Daniel?
Ja, für mich.
Prima, also meine Frage ist, wie typisch, wenn etwas aus der Schweiz kommt, was denn da irgendetwas vorgesehen ist in Richtung Vernichtung des Bankgeheimnisses oder so, in Sachen, ich denke da konkret auf Kontoüberwachung via Internet oder so etwas. Wisst ihr das? Weil ich habe gehört, dass ihr da bestens informiert seid.
Naja, also heute hat gerade der deutsche, wie heißt der hier?
Kanzler heißt der hier.
Kanzler heißt der Mann. Der Schröder hat in der Tat heute gerade angekündigt, dass es weitreichende Einschränkungen des Bankgeheimnisses, zumindest in Deutschland, geben wird. Das heißt vermutlich, dass bei jedwegen strafrechtlichen Ermittlungen oder wenn jemand eben in den Verdacht gerät, nach diesen neuen Terrorismus Gesetzen, hier ist ja bereits das Unterstützen, das finanzielle, direkte und undirekte oder auch bewusste und unbewusste Unterstützen, ist ja dann bereits gleichzusetzen mit der Mitgliedschaft in einer terroristischen Vereinigung. Und wenn man also irgendwie in den Ermittlungsverfahren hat, auf Steuerhinterziehung, wird es eben kein Bankgeheimnis schlicht mehr geben. Also so zumindest die Aussagen und die die Deutsche Bank hat auch gleich gesagt, dass sie sowieso sehr weitreichend kooperieren und so fort. Also im Moment üben die sich natürlich alle darin zu betonen, wie weit sie doch dem Staat entgegenkommen würden, wenn es irgendwie hilft, den Terrorismus einzudämmen. Ob das tatsächlich hilft, ist natürlich eine ganz andere Frage.
Also meine Frage wäre eigentlich gewesen, wie da etwas technisch in der Art, also zum Beispiel die Überwachung des Kontenverkehrs oder so, ob der das detailmäßig wisst oder so.
Ja, das ist relativ einfach. Also die Überwachung von Konten auf verdächtige Transaktionen ist ja mittlerweile eine relativ altbekannte Kunst. Der Großteil der Transaktionen findet in den Banken selbst ja tatsächlich elektronischen Wege statt und alles, was die da tun, ist, dass die bestimmte Schwellwerte zum Beispiel einstellen für Überweisungen und wenn Überweisungen in einer bestimmten Größenordnung rübergehen, dann müssen die manuell autorisiert werden bzw. wenn es dann verdächtig aussieht, das heißt, dass die Führungnahmen komisch aussehen oder halt irgendwie mehrfache Transaktionen stattfinden, dergleichen Dinge mehr, dann müssen die sich halt von sich aus an die Überwachungsbehörden wenden. Also in Deutschland zum Beispiel ist es so, dass diese Geldwäsche-Gesetz gibt, wo nach Transaktionen oberhalb einer bestimmten Größenordnung halt tatsächlich von den Banken an die Behörden gemeldet werden.
Die dann nichts unternehmen im Übrigen.
Ist das so?
Die Behörden, ja, ja. Also die Banken melden sich zu Tode und die Behörden unternehmen nichts. Irgendwo im Fernsehen hab ich auch mal einen gesehenen Staatsanwalt, der meinte, na ja, ich glaube zwei Fälle haben wir in diesem Jahr bisher bearbeiten können.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich auch so, dass irgendwie die Treffiganalyse, was da irgendwie tatsächlich an Daten von den Banken gemeldet wird, eigentlich ein interessanter Teil ist. Also muss ja nicht immer gleich an die Staatsanwaltschaften gehen, aber vermutlich ist da ein BND da auch sehr dankbar, darüber relativ zügig Informationen darüber zu kriegen, was bei den Konten aussieht.
Das ist eigentlich das einzige, also um auf eure Frage Antwort zu geben, das einzige, dass ich zu tragen erlaube, was vielleicht wie viel Geld zu wem gegangen wäre. Das ist alle einzige aus meinem Privaten, was ich eigentlich untypisch für Schweizer erfahren würde. Das alles andere, also was mache ich privat, mit wem ich da rede, das geht niemand nichts an. Danke schön.
Welche Freiheiten werdet ihr bereit aufzugeben? Was würdet ihr denn alles über euch ergehen lassen, um solche Terroranschläge möglicherweise in Zukunft verhindert zu wissen?
0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110 Name Micha, jetzt Chaosradio.
Micha?
Ich wollte nur sagen, dass ich zum Beispiel nicht nur Freiheit auf jeden Fall wurde, um mir nur eine Meinung zu setzen, die Schönheiten zu bilden. Ich war gerade im Verhältnis zum Schlagzeilen von der BZ letzten. Ich war beim Laden die Jäger, der ab der Vokalypse warten schon.
Was die BZ in den letzten Wochen veranstaltet hat, ist wirklich extrem, fand ich auch.
Das ist Hetze.
Das ist doch eigentlich schon Demagogie gewesen, oder? So unkommentiert einen Steckbrief von dem Laden abzudrucken.
Das ist auch kein Wunder. Mal gucken, wer Chefredakteur von dem Laden geworden ist. Unser aller Freund Georg Gaffron, sein Zeichens Oberhetzer bei 100, 6. Also insofern ist es nicht weiter wirklich verwunderlich, was die BZ da treibt.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass es die, ich glaube, am meisten gelesene Zeitung in der Stadt ist.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ich meine, früher war die BZ ja noch ganz lustig, da konnte man auch drüber lachen, aber mittlerweile ist er nicht mehr zum Lachen.
Das ist allerdings richtig. Micha, was für Freiheiten würdest du dir denn einschränken lassen?
Also ja, keine nicht wahr und schon gar nicht im Verhältnis dazu nicht wahr, mich zu irgendwas nicht wahr, die im dritten Reich nicht wahr aufhetzen zu lassen, von wegen mit irgendeiner Demagogie nicht wahr, blind durch die Gegend rennen zu sollen, nicht wahr, um für irgendwelche Idioten nicht wahr die Kastanien aus dem Feuer holen zu sollen, nicht wahr. Also jetzt zum Beispiel nicht wahr die Leute nicht wahr, die da auch demonstriert haben nicht wahr, von wegen Amerika unser Bündnispartner war. Also was ich nun absolut nicht verstanden habe nicht wahr, auch gerade im Verhältnis dazu nicht wahr, dass die Amerikaner nicht wahr, normalerweise die Deutschen ja wirklich nicht wahr, nur noch wie eine Bananenrepublik behandeln wahr. Und das auch gerade im Verhältnis dazu nicht wahr, es hier ja kein Anflug von nationaler Solidität mehr durchkommt, auch politisch nicht wahr.
Die Abschaffung der Visa-Pflicht nenne ich nicht unbedingt, die Abschaffung der Visa-Pflicht für die USA nenne ich nicht unbedingt, behandeln wie eine Bananenrepublik.
Da kannst du genau so gut das sehen, was sie hier letztens am Plakaten ausgestellt haben, 50.000 Arbeitsplatzmaßnahmen nicht wahr, für Amerika nicht wahr. Ich meine, wenn wir nicht wahr, oder wenn die Deutschen jetzt nicht wahr, zum Beispiel nicht wahr, eine Arbeitserlaubnis nicht wahr, für Computerspezialisten aus dem Ausland auszustellen nicht wahr, dann wurde das immer so hingetan, nicht wahr, wie wenn das irgendeine Arte wäre, war. Andererseits, ich meine, kickt ja mal irgendwelche Leute an, nicht wahr, die jetzt wirklich nicht wahr, um sich zu dienen nicht wahr und sehen nicht wahr, wenn sie das nicht machen, nicht wahr, nicht nach Amerika gehen, weil dann kommen sie in Deutschland auch nicht weiter, wahr, also das ist ungefähr nicht mehr ähnlich wie in der DDR, nicht wahr, wo du zum Beispiel nicht wahr eine Einladung nach Russland auch nicht ablehnen kannst, wahr, und das ist ungefähr auch alle dieselbe Ebene, nicht wahr, man wurde gezwungen, wahr.
Und das sind die zwanzig...
23 Uhr ist Chaosradio 65. Chaosradio 65 und das war John Lennon mit Imagine. Auch ein Lied, das in den USA derzeit nicht im Radio gespielt wird. Warum? Also Offensive kann es ja doch irgendwie nicht sein.
Na ja, das Frieden halt ich meiner Meinung nach.
Das ist das, was die amerikanische Regierung nicht will.
Nee, Frieden ist gerade nicht so innen.
Nee, nicht wirklich. Was war unsere Frage nochmal?
Genau, welche Maßnahmen wird ihr bereit zu tragen? Was denkt ihr was sinnvoll ist und wo seht ihr eure Grenze?
Genau, mitreden könnt ihr hier.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Kaum reden wir von Überwachung ruft Jörg an.
Ja, hallo Holger. Und hallo ihr anderen zwei.
Drei.
Drei seid ihr insgesamt, oder vier?
Nee, insgesamt sind wir vier.
Also ihr anderen drei.
Also Holger ist mein Name, dann haben wir noch Andreas, Andi und Frank.
Alles klar. Ja, also ich bin bereit das Telefon überwachen zu lassen. Das wird bei mir sowieso schon jahrelang überwacht.
Bist du nur deswegen bereit dein Telefon überwachen zu lassen, oder?
Nee, nicht nur deswegen, weil ich generell der Meinung bin, da hab ich gar nichts dagegen. Ich hab sowieso früher als junger Mensch eine gespaltene Meinung zu Big Brother gehabt. Also ich hab George Orwell den Film gesehen, 1984. Und da dachte ich mir so, nee, wenn das soweit kommt, dann, ich hatte ja so nette Freunde, dann gehst du mit einer Maschinenpistole los und legst die Verantwortlichen um. Aber die Meinung hat sich geändert. Ich meine, aufgrund der veränderten Weltlage und so weiter, wäre eine Überwachung in dem Sinne vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt.
Glaubst du, dass es helfen würde?
Ja, ich glaube schon, denn wer kriminelle Energie hat, der hat etwas zu befürchten. Und wer keine kriminelle Energie hat, der hat nichts zu befürchten.
Glaubst du, da Terroristen dann so blöden Telefon zu benutzen? Ich meine... Also ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob du die Geschichte von irgendwie...
Es gibt ja auch Bilder, Nachrichten oder so. Ich weiß schon, wie das gemacht wird.
Also ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwie irgendein nennenswerter islamischer Terrorist, irgendwie seit die Russen diesen jungen Mann an Tschechienien mit den Raketen weggeputzt haben, die auf sein Mobiltelefon gefallen sind, dass da noch irgendjemand ein Telefon benutzen wird. Insofern können wir Telefonwahl ja schon mal weglassen.
Was benutzt er? Na Mensch, steh dich mal wieder zu. Über der Christi plötzlich Post oder so, oder Christi eine Servum zugesteckt oder so, wo irgendwelche Nachrichten drauf sind. Und das ist ja sehr schwierig, das alles so in den Griff zu kriegen. Ich meine generell, ich hab überhaupt nichts gegen eine Telefonüberwachung. Ich bin der Meinung, es sollte eine parteienübergreifende Kontrolle stattfinden, das Verfassungsschutz, der sowas macht, macht ja hier in Berlin überwiegend der Bausenat, der die Telefone abhört. Und ich meine aber, es müsste hier sowohl von SPD, Grünen, PDS, CDU und weiß ich was, doch alles für Parteien.
Ja, aber dann lass mir dir kurze technische Frage stellen. Wie willst du einen Geheimdienst überwachen? Der ist ja per Definition im Geheimen tätig.
Ich sage, da müsste es ein Gremium geben.
Aber wie soll das arbeiten?
Wollte ich ja gerade erklären, du hast mich ja unterbrochen eben. Ich meine, das müsste ein Gremium geben, dass aus allen Fraktionen, dass da eine kompetente Leute zusammengesetzt werden, die die Berichte, die die anfährt, die Geheimdienste, unsere Geheimdienste, dass die kontrolliert werden, so ähnlich wie ein Datenschutzbeauftragter.
Es gibt doch langs die G10 Kommission, die hilft nicht.
Wie bitte?
Es gibt doch schon langs die G10 Kommission, die tut genau das. Nämlich tatsächlich Anschreiten des Posten Fernmelder.
Es wird sowieso immer Missbrauch geben.
Die Frage ist doch letztendlich, welche Maßnahmen helfen? Wir haben gerade festgestellt, dass Telefonüberwachung gegen Terroristen offenbar Schwachsinn ist. Das heißt, wir können schon mal abhaken. Die interessante Frage ist doch, welche Maßnahmen würden denn tatsächlich irgendwas bringen? Weil Überwachung einzuführen, weil man sich dann sicherer fühlt, ist ja wohl offensichtlich der falsche Weg. Dass du jetzt sagst, okay, das ist egal, weil dein Telefon wird sowieso abgehört, mag ja deine private Meinung sein. Nur, irgendwie wird es sicherlich vielen anderen Leuten nicht so gehen. Die irgendwie denken, dass es irgendwie am Telefon, sich privat unterhalten zu können, schon einfach mal ganz normal dazugehört. Zum normalen Leben und nicht irgendwie überwacht zu werden.
Na, ich sehe eine gewisse Schwierigkeit, weil ich ja schon angedeutet habe, dass es also sehr viele Möglichkeiten gibt, Informationen weiter zu tragen, sei es durch Werbeprospekte, die du in den Briefkasten kriegst, oder plötzlich eine CD von AOL oder sonst irgendwas oder...
Was du gerade sagst, ist das, was eine AOL-CD bringt, Andi?
Nein, ich meine, der Punkt ist doch, dass wer sich irgendwie im Verborgenen verständigen will, der benutzt Verschlüsselung oder Steganografie, der versteckt halt seine Verschlüsselung in Kommunikation, und den werden sie nicht kriegen. Und wenn du allgemeine Telefonüberwachung einführst, wo wir ja eh schon mehr oder weniger kurz davor sind, oder kurz danach in einigen Bereichen, ja, bloß das, was die amerikanische Regierung ja offenbar tut, und das war ja bis vor Kurzem, vor den Anstrengungen, auch noch im Europäischen Parlament die Diskussion, nämlich, dass eben abgehört wird, um irgendwie sich unliebsamen Leute vom Leib zu halten. Aber ich rede ja nicht von Terroristen, und ich rede auch von Wirtschaftsspionage. Das heißt, dass man eben gezielt, die amerikanische Industrie offenbar den einen oder anderen Wind gegeben hat, wenn es um bedeutende Informationen ging, bei Angebotserstellungen und so fort. Und ich meine, die amerikanische Regierung hat ja eben keine Warnung erhalten von ihren Geheimdiensten, was diese Anschläge betrifft, obwohl die möglicherweise ein Telefon hier und da mal benutzt haben.
Angebisch hat der Herr Mossart den amerikanischen...
Ja, aber wenn die amerikanische Regierung eben noch nicht gelernt hat, anderen Leuten zuzuhören, sondern immer nur mitzuhören, dann stellt sich doch die Frage, was all das Mithören dann bringen soll.
Ja, ich hab sowieso eigentlich mal die perverse Meinung vertreten, dass die Geheimdienste aller Länder mehr zusammenarbeiten müssten, damit es mehr Gerechtigkeit gibt und so weiter. Ja, genau, Gerechtigkeit und weniger Hunger auf der Erde und so weiter.
Aber es gibt doch so viel Hunger auf der Erde, weil es die Geheimdienste gibt.
Das hört sich so komisch an, ja ich weiß es. Aber trotzdem, ich sehe darin doch einen Weg, denn es wird immer wieder natürlich Machtinteressen geben und so weiter. Das haben wir jetzt gerade wieder gesehen. Jetzt werden wieder bestimmt Zivilisten sterben müssen. Und das ist scheiße alles. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn da irgendwie einen Konsens gefunden wird, dass die mehr zusammenarbeiten und wirklich den harten kriminellen Kern an Terroristen und an Kriegstreibern, egal ob es Staatsterror ist oder ob es privater Terror ist, von einigen religiösen Fanatikern, es gibt ja auch einen Staatsterror, der ist nicht so untergaben, der ist schwerer noch zu entdecken als ein anderer Terror.
Jörg, bevor Andy irgendwie völlig ausflippt, danke für deinen Anruf.
Okay, tschüss.
Ich mach mal einfach dein Mikrofon so lange aus, weil du lässt ihn ja noch nicht mal ausreden.
Ach, ich lass ihn doch ausreden.
Was ist denn eigentlich?
Ich wollte ja mit dem Mann noch diskutieren.
Diese Sachen, Diskussionen erfordert aber auch, dass man einander ausreden lässt. Da gab's doch mal ein ISDN-Telefon, das verschlüsselt, oder nicht?
Ja, gab es auch. Es gab einen jungen Mann, der eine Diplomarbeit gemacht hat. Der hat dieses Projekt leider nicht überlebt. Es gibt auch andere Leute, die versucht haben, verschlüsselte Kommunikationen weitflächig einzuführen. Das haben auch nicht alle überlebt. Also das Problem ist erinnert, es gibt natürlich Geheimnisse, die das alles mithören wollen, bloß die Frage ist, sind die ein Teil der Lösung oder sind die ein Teil des Problems?
Das ist eine interessante Frage. Fragen wir jemand anderen. Name Bodo.
Bodo!
Sie wollen heute alle nicht mit uns sprechen, das ist furchtbar. Wahrscheinlich weil wir AULCD gesagt haben. Daniel? Hey Freunde, Daniel? Na hey, es funktioniert ja. Du bist jetzt mal dran?
Was ich ursprünglich sagen wollte war eigentlich nur, dass wenn jemand überwacht wird oder kontrolliert wird, dass dann sozusagen mitgeteilt werden muss, ob man überwacht wird. Ganz einfach.
Im Moment der Überwachung?
Ja genau. Also wenn man unter Verdacht steht, dass es mitgeteilt wird. Große Transparenz einfach.
Also ist die Überwachung ja hinfällig.
Ja aber das allein, dass man überwacht wird, würde doch...
Wahrscheinlich eine Verhaltensänderung überwachten hervorrufen.
Oder nicht.
Was würdest du tun, wenn jemand sagt du wirst überwacht? Hältst du dich anders am Telefon?
Aber generell schon, wenn ich Terrorist wäre auf jeden Fall.
Naja, und bei den Überwachungsmaßnahmen geht es ja zumindest offiziell darum, die Terroristen zu überführen und ihnen die Straftaten nachzuweisen, wenn man es ihnen sagt, dass sie überwacht werden.
Es geht ja um die Sicherung der Allgemeinheit. Und das funktioniert am besten. Also ich werde die Leute nicht unbedingt bestrafen, aber ich will es erstmal vermeiden.
Dein Konzept ist eher Dinge zu verhindern statt nachträglich die Leute dafür zur Rechenschaft zu ziehen.
Schaff ziehen natürlich, aber als erstes das vermeiden.
Du hast einen Ansatz.
Also... So wie es passiert ist jetzt, das ist ja... Die Konsequenz im Prinzip. Weil irgendwas versäumt wurde. Ähm, dass die USA... sich... quergestellt haben in einer Menge von Dingen. Was jetzt ähm... den Kongress angeht.
Na gut, das werden sie auch weiterhin tun. Wird es nutzen, wenn wir sämtliche Telefone abhören? Also wird das das ändern, was die USA möglicherweise verbocken?
Hey, sie sollen voraussehen einfach. Bestrafen bringt ja dann auch nichts, weil dann ist ja schon der Unfall im Prinzip passiert.
Bestrafen bringt vor allen Dingen nur dann, was wir an Druckmittel haben. Ich glaube, das hat niemand. Daniel, ich danke für deinen Anruf. Äh, eine ähnliche Meinung vertritt, glaube ich, Markus.
Also erst mal möchte ich diesem Typen, der gerne eine totale Überwachung der Telefone will, total widersprechen, weil letztendlich möchte ich nicht irgendwo, wenn ich mit meiner Freundin über irgendwas Privates spreche, dass da irgend so ein Typ, den Lüster dahinter sitzt und ja, sich das Ganze reinziehen kann.
Was besprichst du denn nur so mit deiner Freundin?
Na ja, das geht hier nicht lang. Im Prinzip würde letztendlich doch diese Telefonüberwachung dazu führen, dass Leute, die auf irgendeine andere Art und Weise Oppositionen hegen gegen das System, das es gibt, nicht unbedingt radikal sind, trotzdem irgendwo letztendlich möglicherweise repressalen Nachsicht ziehen. Weil die Daten ja letztendlich auch vielleicht sogar weitergegeben werden an andere Stellen. Andererseits müsste man noch sagen, die Verbindung, wo gesagt wurde, dass man die Geheimdienste untereinander mehr und mehr aneinander bringen müsste, das geht so oder so nicht. Weil letztendlich kochen die eh an die eigenen Süppchen. Das heißt, weil die letztendlich auch darauf bestrebt sind, im vier eigenen Land immer den eigenen Vorteil rauszuziehen, durch die Geheimdienstearbeit. Im Grundsatz könnte man diese gesamte Terroraktion nur dann stoppen, wenn man die Ursachen des Terrors an sich bekämpft. Das würde bedeuten, dass die USA an sich eine gesamte andere Politik einstreben müsste. Eine, die nicht durch die Ökonomie geleitet ist, sondern wirklich auf der Tatsache, dass gerechte Politik gemacht werden muss. Das heißt im Grundsatz überhaupt die Probleme, die letztendlich in dem Gefälle zwischen der ersten und der dritten Welt entstanden sind, diese zu beseitigen. Das heißt in den Ländern Verhältnisse zu schaffen, dass kein Panatismus und Hass letztendlich Terror gebührt.
Ich will dir eine kurze Frage stellen. Ich finde das nicht falsch, was du sagst, aber die Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, werden die Amerikaner sozusagen auf diesen Weg kommen? Werden sie das lernen? Der Saddam Hussein hat ja über das Lernen der Amerikaner, man kann zu Saddam Hussein natürlich auch verschiedene Meinungen haben, aber er hat gesagt, die Amerikaner könnten jetzt gerade viel lernen und es wäre besser, sie tun es jetzt, als sie tun es aus dem, was noch kommen mag.
Die Applausi haben wir doch schon am 11. September gekriegt, als George Bush, der blöd Mann, kurz nachdem das Ganze passiert ist, seine dumme Fresse aufgemacht hat und er angefangen zu reden von Rache und Vergeltung. Ab dem Moment hat er schon die Entscheidung getroffen für uns alle. Leider ist es so. Im Prinzip können wir uns alle jetzt so dolle Gedanken machen darüber, wie man jetzt gegen den Terror vorgehen könnte und wie man es macht, ist es trotzdem falsch. Weil letztendlich wird der Terror auch mal wieder seine Wege finden, durch die verschärften Netzwerke seinen Weg zu finden. Im Prinzip gibt es nur ein Fazit, was man darauf ziehen kann, dass es keinen direkten Schutz vor Terror gibt. Man fängt jetzt wirklich an, in die Länder eine stabile Politik zu starten, die erstens dafür sorgt, wenn jetzt die Nordallianz zum Beispiel jetzt unterstützt wird in einem Kampf und diese dann auch umfangsiegt, möglicherweise, dass die Amerikaner nicht dann wieder losgehen und dann irgendeinen Herrscher an der Macht lassen, wie es ja im Irak passiert ist, der Hossien blieb ja nur an der Macht, weil die Amerikaner Angst davor hatten, dass in diesem Machtwirkung, was entstand, wieder ein Bürgerkrieg ausbricht und möglicherweise radikal an die Macht kommt. Das heißt also, dass letztendlich nachhaltig in solchen Konflikten eine Lösung gefunden wird. Unter anderem hätte es auch schon lange seit Jahrzehnten eine Lösung stattfinden müssen im Nord-Ost-Konflikt, wurde aber nicht gemacht, weil da viel zu viele amerikanische und europäische Interessen dran hängen. Und solange dort irgendwo immer die Geldfrage und die Frage der Märkte von Entscheidung ist, wird sich dort auch nichts ändern. Das steckt immerhin der gesamte Industrie dahinter. Zurzeit kreist eine gesamte Industrie hinter George Bush im Rücken, die unbedingt diesen Krieg wahrscheinlich auch wollen, um die eigenen Waffen wieder auszutesten. Und andererseits wollen die danach auch nicht dort drinnen bleiben im Land, weil die garantiert dort keine Märkte finden würden. Das Land wäre viel zu teuer, es wieder aufzubauen, um letztendlich dort irgendwelche Profits zu starten.
Das weiß ich nicht, so sehe ich es ungefähr.
Also keine Maßnahmen außer Änderungen der Umstände. Ich lese übrigens gerade, dass der Bundeskanzler sich mit dem Ministerpräsidenten der Länder getroffen hat und sie jetzt also vorhaben, die Rasterfahndung uneingeschränkt und bundesweit durchzuziehen und durchzusetzen. Haben wir eine kleine Musik von unserer Liste?
Das ist Fire von Arthur Brown.
Ich bin der Gott des Heils, und ich bringe dir...
Chaosradio 65, Freiheit im Zeichen des Terrores ist unser Thema hier auf Fritz. Ich zitiere kurz mal Spiegel online. Italiens Ministerpräsident Silvio Berlusconi behauptet, die westliche Zivilisation sei der islamischen Welt überlegen und sollte sich dessen im Kampf gegen den internationalen Terrorismus bewusst sein. Was also unser Taschen...
Du gehst auf den nächsten Satz, das wird ja noch schlimmer.
Was war das noch? Ach ja genau. Zudem nahm er Globalisierungsgegenens wie sie. Was ich aber auch interessant finde ist, dass unser Taschenduscher aus Italien meint, die westliche Zivilisation sei der islamischen Welt überlegen. Hat denn mal jemand erzählt, dass die Muslime uns das Schreiben und Rechnen beigebracht haben? Also das ist ihm wahrscheinlich ein bisschen entgangen, oder?
An dieser Stelle würde ich gerne Irina Gandhi zitieren, der mal gefragt wurde, Mr. Gandhi, what do you think about Western civilization? Und er antwortete, oh, that would be a great idea.
Ja und außerdem nahm er die Globalisierungsgegner ins Visier.
Der hat halt gleich gesagt, das sind auch Terroristen, die wir uns bei der Klinge halt aufwenden sollten.
Und so behandelt er sie ja auch, wenn sie in sein Land kommen, oder?
Ja, die Faschos kommen, oder?
Genau, Stichwort Faschos. Was wir ja gerne von unseren Hörern wissen wollen, was würdet ihr denn so zum Thema Fingerabdrücke in Personalausweisen und Reisepässen denken, was ja auch eine der Maßnahmen war, die unser glorioser Innenminister zur Abwehr der schrecklichen Terrorismusgefahr vorgeschlagen hat und wo wir uns alle doch ganz deutlich fragen, was es denn wo für einen Sinn bringt. Das würde uns doch mal interessieren, wer von euch wäre dann bereit da mal zum nächsten Polizeirevier zu gehen, da seine Fingerabdrücke abzugeben und dann entsprechend einen schönen Aufgabe auf sein Pase zu bekommen.
031 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Die Frage ist wer glaubt, dass man dadurch irgendetwas verhindert. Also ich meine in Amerika waren ja einige der Leute auf der Terrorliste, die sind trotzdem ins Flugzeug gekommen und sie hätten auch bei Vollageres Personalausweis ihre richtigen Fingerabdrücke drin gehabt oder nicht?
Das war gefälscht, aber ich meine das kann man ja auch fälschen.
Das kann man sogar aufkleben oder sowas.
Hallo?
Möchtest du gerne deinen Fingerabdruck in deinem Perso haben?
Nee, eigentlich weniger. Zu dem Thema wollte ich eigentlich was sagen, nämlich Thema innere Sicherheit. Und zwar habe ich da auch einen Spiegelartikel drüber gelesen, bezogen auf den G8-Gipfel. Und zwar ging es ja grundlegend auch um innere Sicherheit, bezogen auf Hooligans ursprünglich. Da wurde ja ein Gesetz eben, wie sagt man, vorbereitet. Genau. Und zwar wurden ja in dem Fall dann einfache Demonstranten katalogisiert. Also nicht nur Hooligans, was sich jetzt beim G8-Gipfel herausgestellt hat, als einfache Demonstranten wie gesagt nicht die Grenzen passieren durften. In dem Zeitraum des G8-Gipfels in Genua. Und zwar, ja, wie gesagt, bin ich in der Meinung, dass es eher den einfachen Bürger trifft. Solche, ja, solche Gesetzgebungen für die innere Sicherheit, wie zum Beispiel Telefon abhören, ähnliches. Ja, das sag ich mal einfache Cannabis zu sich nehmen, mal sozusagen, dass verfolgt werden in Bayern extrem zum Beispiel alles Punkte, die eigentlich auch die innere Sicherheit betreffen, jetzt bezogen auf Fingerabdruck im Personalausweis. Ich weiß nicht, wie gesagt, der Terrorist wird wohl kaum telefonieren. Ja, also ich bin der Meinung, es trifft kaum den Terroristen. Ja, ich denke, man müsste da eben, wie ich glaube, der Markus gesagt hat, da auch erst mal selbstkritisch die eigene Politik betrachten, die ja scheinbar Boden gibt für Terrorismus. Also man müsste ja die Ursachen bekämpfen.
Ich würde gerne eine Frage stellen, nämlich glaubst du, dass zum Beispiel ein Schili, das der tatsächlich glaubt, dass er Terrorismus eindämpft, wenn er jetzt irgendwie einen Fingerabdruck im Personalausweis einführt? Schili schon. Oder ist das nur, nee, nein, nein, ich meine, das meine ich jetzt als ernsthafte Frage. Sind das Maßnahmen, die die da planen, wo sie tatsächlich glauben, den Terrorismus anzudämpfen, oder zielt das von vornherein auf andere Ziele ab und dieser Terrorismus dient im Grunde genommen nur als Vorwand, deiner Meinung nach?
Man könnte es fast behaupten, ja nur da bin ich halt auch sehr vorsichtig. Wie ich das dann wiederum formuliere, sag ich mal, eben aufgrund dessen, ja es könnte schon sein, dass es letztlich eher auf die totale Kontrolle hinausläuft.
Die Frage ist, ob man damit Terrorismus verhindert?
Ja genau und mein Freund meinte zum Beispiel vorhin, sinnvoll wäre dann doch am ehesten noch als erstes Mal so eine Art Volkszählung, sag ich mal. Es gibt so viele Menschen in unserem Land, die ja gar nicht offiziell hier Aufenthaltsgenehmigung haben, beziehungsweise von denen man halt nicht weiß offiziell. Soweit ich weiß, gibt es hier in Berlin eine relativ hohe Dunkelziffer an nicht katalogisierten Menschen, sag ich mal. Also habe ich zumindest gehört, ich komme jetzt nicht direkt aus Berlin, ich komme aus Würzburg. Ja, also das ist so mein Statement dazu. Ich sehe es wie gesagt sehr selbst, sehr kritisch, auch kritisch unserer Politik gegenüber der amerikanischen Politik gegenüber vor allem und bin auch noch der Meinung, wer sagt eigentlich oder wer kann wirklich sagen, es war die Gruppe von Osama bin Laden. Soweit ich weiß, hat Bush jetzt recht umweltvernichtende Politik gemacht die letzte Zeit. Es könnten genauso ja irgendwelche Umweltfanatiker gewesen sein, die jetzt da gegen die amerikanische Politik vorgehen wollten.
Das ist ein interessanter Gedanke, der mir so noch nicht gekommen ist. Die Frage ist, hätte man dann nicht ein etwas umweltfreundlichere Form eines Anschlags gewählt. Aber gut, das ist vielleicht zu absurd.
Nur der Gedanke eben aufgrund dessen, dass so schnell gesagt wurde, ja der Osama bin Laden steckt dahinter. Wir greifen jetzt Afghanistan an, ja?
Wird auch die Frage nach, können Feindbilder sein, die man bereits hat?
Ja genau, diese Feindbilder, wie gesagt. Und deswegen meine ich ja diese selbstkritische Beobachtung der eigenen Politik. Das wäre halt notwendig, aber es traut sich ja letztlich keiner offen zu sagen.
Bemerkenswert ist heute, hat sich hier Stolper geäußert, seines Zeichens bayerischer Ministerpräsident, dass ja die von Herrn Schill in Hamburg jetzt geforderten Maßnahmen zum größten Teil in Bayern bereits eingeführt und wohl erprobter Standard sein. Man sich ja auch fragen mag, ob man vielleicht nicht in Zukunft die bayerische Politik etwas näher betrachtet, die ja auch vielleicht ob ihrer früheren Besatzung durch amerikanische Streitkräfte während der letzten 50 Jahre schon eine gewisse Annäherung an die US-Politiker haben.
Die US-Politik ist sowieso seit 50 Jahren bei uns, beziehungsweise ist ja Grundlage unserer Politik, unserer Demokratie. Also die haben seit 50 Jahren die Finger drin, sag ich mal. Von daher glaube ich auch, dass es schwierig ist für Deutschland da eine wirklich eigene, souveräne Politik zu machen. Auch heute jetzt noch, selbst nach 50 Jahren.
Danke Miriam.
Okay, bitte.
So, jetzt hören wir mal wieder unser Lieblingslied. Erklär nochmal Frank, was das ist, damit wir hier nicht unmittelerregend sind.
Ich weiß nicht genau, Holger, willst du das irgendwie dauernd hören?
Ich will das gar nicht dauernd hören, das kann nicht wahr sein. Das ist meine Sendung.
Also was wir jetzt nochmal hören, ist nochmal wie ein amerikanisches Propagandali, das irgendwie auf den Metierstützpunkten dieser Welt gespielt wurde, um die amerikanischen Truppen da irgendwie auf ihre zukünftigen Aufgaben einzustimmen.
Das Wetter.
Heute Nacht gibt's Nebel bei Temperaturen zwischen 9 und 7 Grad. Morgen zieht dann Bewölkung auf und im Norden regnet's als erstes und dann irgendwann vermutlich und wahrscheinlich sogar sicher im Rest des Landes bzw. der Länder, weil noch sind wir ja nicht fusioniert.
Die Meldung jetzt wird gesiedelt kühnlich.
Bund und Länder sind sich einig, das Bankgeheimnis zu lockern, um den Terrorismus zu bekämpfen. Das sagte Bundeskanzler Schroder nach einem Treffen mit den Regierungschefs der Länder. Außerdem wurde vorgeschlagen, die Rastafanung bundesweit zu nutzen und in einem unbeschränkten Austausch von Polizeidaten zu ermöglichen. Mehrere Friens- und Literatur-Novellpreisträger haben sich gegen einen Krieg in Afghanistan ausgesprochen. Im ARD-Magazin Monitor warnten sie vor einer Spirale der Gewalt. Zu Wort meldeten sich unter anderem der südafrikanische Bischof Desmond Tutu, der Schriftsteller Günter Grass und der Theaterregisseur Dario Faux. Das UNO-Flüchtlingshilfswerk hat dazu aufgerufen, ein Notprogramm für Flüchtlinge aus Afghanistan aufzulegen. Es soll einen Umfang von mehr als 250 Millionen Dollar haben. Das deutsche Entwicklungsministerium stellte 15 Millionen Mark als Soforthilfe bereit. Die NATO hat heute eine Nachfolgemission von Mazedonien beschlossen. Unter deutscher Führung will das Bündnis nun Soldaten zum Schutz von etwa 200 zivilen Beobachtern von EU und Ost-ZE nach Mazedonien entsenden. Und zum Sport. In der Fußball Champions League gab es heute Abend folgende Ergebnisse. Schalke 04 unterlag Real Mallorca 0 zu 1 und Boa Vista Porto schlug Borussia Dortmund 2 zu 1.
Freitag ab 22 Uhr auf Ritz.
Der Computer Musikplumul. Da geht's ums Musikmachen mit dem Computer. Mit viel Musik, die gar nicht elektronisch klingen muss und Leuten, die darüber reden wollen, nämlich euch. Ein Schwerpunkt liegt diesmal auf Einsteigerprogrammen von Magix. Und natürlich wie immer wollen wir eure selbstgemachten Tracks hören. Was ihr dafür tun müsst, erfahrt ihr auf www.fritz.de.
Buste klicken.
Der Computer Musikplumul mit Volker Duispol. Freitag ab 22 Uhr.
Das ist das Hörer.
Genau. Das ist schon noch ein anrufender Anrufer.
Anrufender Anrufer?
Haben wir.
Mitreden könnt ihr übrigens auch unter 0331 77 97 110 Chaosradio 65, Sieh auf Fritz. Wie war das Freiheit im Zeichen des Terrors? Wunderbar. Wer hat sich das ausgedacht?
Ich weiß nicht, Tim glaube ich, ne?
Tim. Hat er wieder Haschisch geraucht. Willst du deinen Fingerabdruck in Ausweis machen? Hast du so einen großen Daumen?
Nee, wenn man alle Finger nimmt, um ganz sicher zu gehen.
Stimmt, man kann es auch digital speichern.
Und überhaupt, wie sieht es mit Fuß-
und Fußabdrücke? Ja, am besten lässt sich man gleich einen Tipp implantieren. Am besten.
Was würdest du machen, wenn du morgens am Briefkasten einen Brief findest, wo deine Freunde von der Ordnung und Sicherheit dich bitten, dich in deinem Polizeirevier einzufinden, um deine Identität zu bestätigen, für einen Fingerabdruck?
Ich glaube, ich würde den Brief erstmal wegschmeißen.
Ich habe einen Anwalt im Haus, ich gehe nur runter und sage.
Hier, kümmere dich mal. Ja, dann bin ich nicht da. Dann kommen wir morgen, dann bin ich auch nicht da.
Ich glaube, es wäre sicherlich eine hervorragende Maßnahme, um die Zivilcourage und die Verweigerungshaltung in Deutschland zu verstärken.
Um da eine Verweigerungshaltung zu kriegen, müsstest du aber dieses Fingerabdruck geben, mit Fußball oder Benzinpreis in Verbindung bringen. Damit kriegst du massenmobilisiert.
Du meinst, Benzinpreis wird erhöht, damit wir teure Reisepässe drucken können?
Genau, so was in der Richtung.
Zierentenspar haben wir gerade.
Oh, das fällt mir an, ich muss ja echt...
So was doch für die Sicherheit auch.
Einmal gegen den Terror rauchen hier. Ich tu das hier nur für euch, wollte ich mal sagen.
Du machst uns alle ganz sicher.
Vor allen Dingen den Rauchmelder.
Um noch mal auf das Thema zurückzukommen. Das Problem mit der Zivilcourage ist ja tatsächlich, wenn man sich diese ganzen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen anguckt, die da beschlossen werden sollen, also zum Beispiel auch dieser neue Paragraph 129b, finde ich, ist das eine erhebliche Einschränkung meiner persönlichen Freiheit.
Erklär doch mal den Unwissenden, was 129b ist.
Also das ist der Paragraph 129 im Strafgesetzbuch, ist mal in den 70er Jahren erfunden worden, um also den Terror besser bekämpfen zu können. Und 129a ist also der Paragraph, in dem die Unterstützung und das Werben für eine terroristische Vereinigung unter Strafe gestellt wird. Aber das bezog sich bisher halt nur auf Organisationen, die hierzulande tätig sind oder waren. Und 129b ist jetzt die geplante Erweiterung, wo das eben auch für terroristische Organisationen oder sogenannte terroristische Organisationen im Ausland gelten soll. Und das Problem ist, damit wird jedweder politische Arbeit platt gemacht im Grunde. Also wenn ich irgendwie ein Plakat von den Zabatistas hier hängen habe, wäre das unsere Werbung dann für eine terroristische Vereinigung. Und ja, damit könnten sie mich dann dran kriegen.
So, so sie denn als terroristisch definiert wird. Wer macht denn das eigentlich?
Das ist, genau, das ist das Problem. Mit diesem bis jährigen 129a wurde einfach davon ausgegangen, dass hier ja irgendwie so Rechtsstaatlichkeit herrscht und alles prima ist. Und das kann man für andere Staaten eben nicht so unbedingt sagen. Also man kann vielleicht nicht unbedingt davon ausgehen, weiß ich, dass Länder in Südamerika zum Beispiel so rechtsstaatlich verfasst sind, wie so hierzulande üblich ist. Wo man da auch noch Kritik äußern kann, wie das hierzulande ist. Und das Problem ist einfach, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft aber tätig werden muss. Und das heißt, man gibt die Definitionsmacht an die Gerichte oder an Staatsanwälte ab. Und das geht nicht. Also das ist genau das Ding mit diesem 129b, dass man eben nicht davon ausgehen kann, dass es in anderen Ländern genauso aussieht wie hier. Wo man sich fragen muss, ab wann ist denn Widerstand gerechtfertigt?
Na ja, und zumal irgendwie noch nicht mal ganz klar ist, dass nicht auch in diesem Land irgendwie die Zappartisten als Terroristen definiert werden würden. Ich meine, das ist halt immer die Frage, das eine Terrorist ist, das andere ein Freiheitskämpfer. Das ist halt immer genau die Diktationsfrage.
Dann nehmen wir mal die Palästinenser als Beispiel.
Das ist genau, aber eine ziemliche Geradwanderung. Zum Beispiel könnte die PLO ihr Büro hier dicht machen. Und das ist genau das Problem jetzt, was ich mit diesen treuen Sicherheitsgesetzen habe. Dass ich da mich schon eingeschränkt fühle in meiner politischen Arbeit.
Und was ist deine politische Arbeit?
Äh, ne, zurzeit ist sie ganz brav, total offiziell. Im Bundestag arbeiten.
Du arbeitest im Bundestag?
Tatsächlich, ja.
Donnerwetter?
Aber in einem Büro...
Ach so, du sitzt da nicht und liest Bildzeitungen wie die ganzen?
Doch, das muss man auch. Das ist total wichtig. Man weiß immer, was die Sache ist.
Medienarbeit, hurra.
Medienarbeit, hurra, sagte die Stimme.
Ja, Medienbeobachtung, genau.
Und da drängt sich dann ja bei 129b auch noch die Frage auf, ab wann das denn strafbar ist. Also was, wenn ich heute die Palästinenser unterstütze, wo es ja nicht strafbar ist, was ist, wenn morgen dieses Gesetz verabschiedet wird? Werde ich dann für gestern bestraft?
Nee, rückwirkend funktioniert das nicht. Aber ab dann halt, ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo das Gesetz gilt.
Was für eine Maßnahme würdest du denn noch für zulässig halten? Oder für wünschenswert?
Also, zum Beispiel diese Sachen mit der Geldwäsche, dass man da schon ein bisschen drauf achtet, ab einer gewissen Größenordnung, wo Gelder hin verschoben werden, denke ich, ja.
Ja, aber ich meine, machen wir uns doch mal nichts vor, da wird schon drauf geachtet. Und trotzdem werden Milliarden ins Ausland transferiert, in irgendwelche Steueroasen. Und da sind unsere Banken und zwar alle, massiv daran beteiligt. Also es ist ja offensichtlich müßig, darüber zu sprechen, da irgendwie noch stärker Kontrollmechanismen reinzubringen, weil die Banken werden auch wieder eine Möglichkeit finden, diese Kontrollmechanismen zu umgehen.
Ja klar, das ist genau das Problem, wo Geld mit irgendwas verdient wird, funktioniert das komischerweise auch. Also, sagen wir mal so, das würde ich persönlich hinnehmen, weil bei mir fast konnte nicht so große Geldbeträge gehen. Aber sonst muss man wirklich gucken, was für Maßnahmen bringen es denn überhaupt. Und da sehe ich im Moment keinerlei Maßnahmen, die wirklich so was verhindern würden.
Ich meine, eine mögliche Maßnahme wäre zum Beispiel mal ordentliche Türen ins Cockpit einzubauen. Es gibt halt irgendwie eine Reihe von Maßnahmen, die diesen spezifischen Anschlag...
Aber dann wird es auch wieder absurd, wenn dann bewaffnete Fluggegleiter auf einmal eingesetzt werden, wo man sich fragt, haben die denn auch Geschosse, die dann von der Flugzeugwand abprallen?
Ja, ja, das ist ein Löcher da rein, damit die Terroristen draußen verfliegen.
Das hab ich mich natürlich auch interessiert, das hab ich mal recherchiert. Es gibt tatsächlich eine Firma in den USA, die leider nicht in der Börse geraten hat, die heißt Gelaser und die baut genau solche Geschosse, mit denen man auch in Flugzeuge schießen kann, ohne dass man die Flugzeughülle oder irgendwie etwa auch hinter dem Terroristen stehende Passagiere noch mitleidenschaftszieht. Also es hat tatsächlich ein technisch gelöstes Problem und zwar hat LIL das irgendwie seit Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er Jahre im Einsatz und seitdem haben die auch irgendwie zwar schon einige erschossene Flugzeugentführer, aber keine Flugzeugentführer mehr.
Hast du eine Ahnung, wie das gelöst wird?
Das ist eine Teflonkapsel mit Bleistorb drin.
Und die schleicht sich sofort so breit und wird gestoppt, dass nichts passieren kann?
Ist ein bisschen widerlich, aber naja.
Das gibt aber eklige Löcher.
Ulrike, danke für deinen Anruf. Und regier noch schön.
Also ich glaube, in dem Büro, in dem ich arbeite, da ist was mit dem Regieren.
Na dann nimm gefälligst an der politischen Willensbildung teil.
Auf jeden Fall.
Einen schönen Abend noch.
Tschüss.
So und jetzt, hier hat eine Quote, wir müssen ja auch die Quote erfüllen.
Merhan.
Hi, bist du Muslim?
Ich war mal eins.
Da bin ich ja froh, dass du es überhaupt geschafft hast, das Telefon zu bedienen. Weil, ich weiß ja nicht, ob du es wusstest, aber der italienische Ministerpräsident der Meinung ist, dass die westliche Zivilisation der islamischen Welt überlegen sei. Also gratuliere zum Bedienen des Telefons.
Ja, wegen Aufglückssicht, oder? Meilenstein.
Auf was für Freiheiten würdest du denn verzichten?
Ja, ich wollte erst mal sagen, das Ganze wird ja schon verallgemeinert, wie ihr es schon gesagt habt, dass es irgendwie zum absoluten Überwachung irgendwie ausarkt, das Ganze. So als Grund, dass jetzt endlich mal alle überwacht werden können. Aber im Grunde genommen muss man es auch von der Seite sehen, wenn man jetzt genau in dem Raster reinpasst, was die heutzutage untersuchen. Der typische Terrorist, irgendwie unauffällig, Ausländer, am liebsten Moslem dann noch. Und von die Seite wird es eben auch weniger gesehen, wie die Leute sich dann eben halt fühlen.
Wie fühlen sie sich?
Ja komisch, wenn du genau in dem Raster reinpasst, man Nachrichten hört und plötzlich heißt es, man sucht genau der und der Typ, den eigentlich unauffällig und studiert oder sonst so um was. Genau wie jemand ganz normal lebt hier in Deutschland. Ich bin selber Flüchtling. Und seitdem ich hier bin, hab ich mich nicht zur Schule kommen lassen. Warum plötzlich passt du in so einen optimalen Terroristen Raster?
Kriegst du das eigentlich auf der Straße? Benehmen sich die Leute anders? Also in den USA sollte man ja jetzt möglichst kein Araber sein. Sonst kriegt man aufs Maul oder wird erschossen wie die beiden Inder?
Bei mir ist es ein bisschen anders. Ich hab irgendwie so ein bisschen langen Haare und so. Und daher geht das so halbwegs. Also merken tue ich nicht so richtig was.
Langhaariger Bombenleger.
Das ist nur ein Palästinertuch, aber so von Leuten geht es eigentlich. Aber so einfach in diesen Raster rein zu rutschen. So plötzlich ist man, obwohl man nichts gemacht hat, so ziehen sie einen Raster mit drin.
Kennst du irgendwelche politischen Extremisten? Auch noch vielleicht von deiner Zeit, in der du noch im Iran gelebt hast?
Damals waren ja alle Extremisten, wo ich hierher gekommen bin. Also wenn du aus Iran rauskommst, zu dem Zeit, wo ich da war, damals ist ja, wenn so eine politische Wende ist und alle plötzlich nur noch radikale Muslim sind in dem Moment, dann ist jeder ein Extremist.
Ich unterstelle jetzt mal, dass du dich in die Leute rein denken kannst. Kannst du? Wie wäre denen beizukommen? Wie hindern wir zumindest islamische Terroristen daran, überhaupt als Terrorist in Aktion zu treten?
Na ja, das ist eben halt eine Frage. Wenn man so aufgewachsen ist von Kindern und einer reingeprügelt wurde, dass man auf die richtige Seite steht und die anderen sind alle die Bösen, denke ich mal, wird man erstmal nicht so richtig gegen angehen können. Außer man kann die klar machen, Jungs, so richtig ist es nicht, was ihr davor habt. Und dazu muss man natürlich den Willen zeigen und einfach mal überall richtige Politik betreiben. Und nicht einfach jahrelang um die Konflikte auftragen lassen, ohne sich einzumischen. Also nah aus dem Halt. Kann man nicht einfach jahrelang Israel gegen Palästina machen lassen und dabei kurz, wenn in Europa was passiert, alle hinmarschieren lassen. Das finde ich auch irgendwie alleingelassen und bestätigt natürlich.
Also du denkst wirklich, die gesetzlichen, die militärischen, auch die nachrichtendienstlichen Maßnahmen, die da gerade möglicherweise ergriffen werden, nutzen exakt gar nichts?
Ja, die nutzen kurzfristig was, bis alle irgendwie Angst haben und danach geht es wieder von vorne los. Also wenn die jetzt in einer Ausdrunde nicht jetzt den Frieden hinkriegen, dann kriegen sie sowieso nie hin. Und jetzt haben sie gerade den richtigen Druckmittel, um irgendwie mal richten Hebel anzusetzen. Aber ich denke mal, von allen Ecken muss man da rangehen. Nicht nur von einer Seite, sondern man muss einfach mal gucken, dass man überall einfach die Ruhe reinbekommt. Also nicht nur von einer Front kämpfen, sondern einfach wirklich mal Klartext, mal auch überall dafür zu sorgen, dass eine gleichmäßigen Gewichtung da ist. Weil wenn die Amerikaner immer tatsächlich nur auf die israelische Seite stehen, aber trotzdem Palästinner helfen zu verhandeln zum Beispiel, und dann nichts dabei rauskommt, seit Jahrzehnten schon, dann fühlen sie sich immer bestätigt. Und es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als jemanden zu bestätigen, der noch radikal ist.
Ein veredables Schlusswort. Von der Liste. Wir spielen hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz heute Musik von einer Liste, die Radio-Stationen, ne andersrum, es gibt eine Liste in den USA und auf dieser Liste stehen Lieder drauf, die derzeit im US-amerikanischen Radio lieber mal nicht gespielt werden sollten und auch nicht gespielt werden. Und genau deshalb spielen wir die, weil wir denken, dass die trotzdem dazugehört. Weil es wäre so, als würde es aus einer aktiven Sprache einfach ein Wort rausnehmen.
Das sind die Smashing Pumpkins.
The world is a vampire.
Chaosradio 65 auf Fritz Nabind.
interessante Dinge aus der Welt da draußen, der Spiegel berichtet soeben, dass die britische Regierung ihre Medien aufgefordert hat, sich bei der Berichterstattung über geplante Anti-Terror-Maßnahmen zurückzuhalten, da eine eventuelle Berichterstattung die nationale Sicherheit gefährden könnte. Also interessant fand ich den Satz, Zitat, informierte Spekulationen könnten der Wahrheit sehr nahe kommen. Aus Rücksicht auf die Einsätzen beteiligten wäre es hilfreich, wenn Spekulationen auf ein Minimum beschränkt wurden, erklärt die Regierung.
Wie war das? Eine Zensur findet nicht statt?
Genau, eine Zensur findet nicht statt. Es handelt sich halt um Maßnahmen der nationalen Sicherheit. Das müssen sie doch verstehen. Ich meine, sie haben auch da hinten einen Kasten mit Notfallmusik steht.
Ja, in der Tat. Das hat aber weniger mit Zensur zu tun, sondern es hat damit zu tun, dass bisweilen Menschen hier Sendungen machen, die tatsächlich unangemessene Musik für den jeweiligen Zeitpunkt, die nur in ihrer Plattenkiste haben. Also was weiß ich, wenn du jetzt ein Rachel Gansdermachine Special machst, beispielsweise und währenddessen bombardiert jemand Berlin.
Das wäre doch mal genau der Soundtrack, oder?
Ja, aber im Rundfunkrad sitzen auch Christen, weißt du? Nee, das will man dann vielleicht doch nicht haben.
Das ergibt mich sowieso immer, dass in den Filmen gibt es immer Soundtracks zu den Katastrophen.
Die hier von Enya hat doch satt einen so schön zusammenschnitten.
Soundtracks nicht irgendwie gedudelt, fast gut.
Ach so, richtigen Soundtracks.
Ja, also mit dramatischen Höhepunkten an diesen Dingen.
Ich glaub, du bist krank. Freier dem Zeichen des Terrors ist unser Thema heute im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Haben wir noch Fragen an die Hörer?
Wir hatten ja eigentlich noch die Frage, ob du gerne deine Fingerabdrücke im Personalausweis haben möchtest.
Hey, da haben wir doch eine schöne Antwort. Hallo, Manu.
Fingerabdruck? Ja, Fingerabdruck, gute Frage. Ich hätte noch eine radikalere Möglichkeit, wenn ich mal ein Strichkutter auf die Stirn hab. Dann kann man damit zum Lesegerät durch die Menge gehen und dann weiß man immer, wie ich er ist.
Ja, und damit wär man dann ganz dicht am Buch der Offenbarung. Da war noch mal irgendwie so eine Stelle drin.
Ich denke, aber da war es glaube ich der Handrücken, wenn ich jetzt nicht, oder?
Richtig, der Handrücken, auf dem das Zeichen des Tiers vermarkt sei und niemand wird mehr kaufen und verkaufen können, ohne dass er dieses Zeichen trägt.
Genau, genau. Naja, wer weiß, vielleicht kommt es ja noch so weit. Also das wäre zumindest irgendwie so eine Möglichkeit, die man jetzt irgendwie so gleich machen kann. Leute in Tätowierstudies schicken und halt diese Striche da drauf kratzen. Und irgendwie vor einiger Zeit hab ich mit einem Bekannten unterhalten und der studiert Biologie und der hatte auch eine recht interessante Idee. Und zwar, dass man doch so mit jedem kleine Stücke kodieren kann, die man dann Leuten ins Erbgut einpflanzt, sodass man halt mit einem Tropfen Blut irgendwie feststellen kann, wenn man ist so allergettert.
Das ist ein bisschen aufwendig.
Aber nicht mehr lange.
Ich weiß nicht, aber heutzutage gibt es ja schon Firmen, die sich darauf spezialisiert haben, sicherzustellen für so große Nahrungsmittelketten, dass zum Beispiel bestimmte Fleischbestandteile nur von ihren Züchtern kommen, mit denen sie heute Verträge haben. Das funktioniert dann so, dass ihnen hat den Viechanhalter, wenn sie geboren werden, ein Sample abgenommen wird. Das wird dann an eine große Datenbank gespeist. Und wenn die Viecher dann am Schlachthof ankommen, beziehungsweise in der Verarbeitung, wird halt wieder ein Sample gezogen. Das wird halt gegen die Datenbank gefahren, geguckt, ob das Viech auch tatsächlich irgendwie von dem Vertragszüchter kam oder sie es irgendwo billig eingekauft haben. Also, die Technologie existiert.
Das heißt, wir müssen einfach nur das, was wir mit Tieren machen, kontrequell auf Menschen anwenden und...
Genau, interessanterweise nehmen die die Samples beim Ohrlochstechen, wenn sie irgendwie diese Marken gegen Kühe verpassen.
Na, das könnte man ja mit der Wind... Die ganzen Gebirge vom TV ist jetzt aber ein Problem. Das könnte man ja mit der Wind...
Zumindest alle gefährlichen Leute haben sich mal ein Ohrloch stechen lassen oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, also wenn ein Kind geboren wird, dann wird dem ja auch sofort irgendwie ein paar Sekunden nach der Geburt gleich Blut abgenommen, um auf ein paar Abkrankheiten zu testen, gegen die man gleich irgendwie Medikamente geben müsste oder so. Ich meine, das wird ja auch gemacht. Und da gleich irgendwie einen Tropfen abzuzweigen und dann da halt irgendwie Gensequenzen rauszukopieren, die halt Menschen eindeutig identifizieren, wär auch kein Problem. Mein Computer, das sind leistungsfähig genug, dass man den ganzen Müll dann speichert. Denke ich mal.
Ja, also ich meine, die Datenbanken sind groß genug, ne?
Ja, also da sehe ich nicht so das Problem drin. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit man dann halt irgendwie auf den entsprechenden Positionen schon drüber nachdenkt. Also hoffen wir mal nicht, aber auszuschließen ist es halt nicht. Das ist das Problem, das ich damit hab. Weil ich meine, wenn man sich mal so die Entwicklung im Augenblick anschaut, also so allzu weit bis zu Orwell, haben wir es dann glaube ich nicht mehr.
Wie viele Jahre noch?
Je nachdem, also noch ein solcher Terroranschlag und dann, weiß ich nicht, würde ich mal sagen, fünf bis zehn Jahre ungefähr, je nachdem, je nach Heftigkeit, wie man das halt jetzt anpackt.
Übrigens der Lärm im Hintergrund kommt daher, dass Frank gerade meint, den Fernseher anmachen zu müssen. Damit ich wirklich umgehen kann.
Weil der ist mit grafischer Oberfläche.
Herr Leutawald, wir gleich über mit dem Orwell-Trieb, hast du natürlich recht. Die Frage ist, wird es der amerikanischen Regierung oder der amerikanischen Sicherheit besonders viel nutzen? Die haben jetzt auch darüber diskutiert, dass sie an den Flughäfen Gesichtskontrollen einführen. Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, Entschuldigung. Elektronische Gesichtskontrollen, das eben, das ist wirklich unglaublich. Also wer auf MTV gerade die Möglichkeit hat, MTV zu gucken, da wird jetzt tatsächlich gerade dieser Sänger dabei, der bei Wack the Dog eben im Auftrag des amerikanischen Präsidenten da einen Propagandaschlacht führt. Genau der ist jetzt gerade auf MTV zu sehen, wie er an seiner Italie herumschreddelt. Also man weiß nicht, ob es Wack the Dog 1 oder Teil 2 ist.
Entschuldigung.
Naja, ganz kurz diese Sache, die sie in Amerika da einführt. Ich fand das aus einem anderen Grund noch bemerkenswert. Nämlich elektronische Gesichtskontrollen ist das, was sie dort diskutieren. Das kostet ihnen natürlich auch Geld. Aber was sie offenbar nicht diskutieren, ist zum Beispiel ihrem Sicherheitspersonal mal beizubringen, dass man Leute nicht nur fragt, ob sie einen schwitzen Gegenstand dabei hat, sondern eventuell auch sich auf den Fall vorbereitet, dass ein Terrorist nicht sagen wird, ja, ich habe ein Messer dabei, ja, ich will dieses Flugzeug entführen.
Wenn ich das kurz sagen darf, ist das sowieso irgendwie totaler Unfug. Weil ich mein, irgendwie alles, was ich irgendwie für das Entführen eines Flugzeugs brauche, das finde ich an Bord von einem Flugzeug. Also da brauche ich nicht großartig irgendwie Messer oder sowas mit an Bord.
Nee, jedes Flugzeug hat eine Axt an Bord. Ich meine, dann kannst du wunderbare Späße machen. Also kannst du im Zweifelsfall auch mal die Handblühe durchschlagen.
Davon reicht es ja ohnehin, den Piloten davon zu überzeugen, dass man gefährlich ist. Na wie gesagt, also ich denke mal, der einzig sinnvolle Weg ist da einigermaßen, solide Türen ins Cockpit einzubauen und den Jungs beizubringen, dass sie egal was da hinten passiert, diese Türen nicht aufmachen.
Die Frage, die ich mir stelle ist, wenn man nach Amerika einreist, da gibt es auch diese grünen Ankreuzkarten. Und da soll man ja auch sagen, ob man als Terrorist einreist.
Da gibt es doch so eine Simpsons-Folge, wie irgendwie Homer nach Kuba geht und dann so Castro-Ammorden angreuzt auf der Karte, so was davor.
So ungefähr sieht das aus. Vielleicht hat das auch alles nur mit dem amerikanischen Bildungsniveau zu tun und ist in Wirklichkeit überhaupt kein Terrorismusproblem.
Niveau ist ja auch nicht der passende Begriff.
Manu, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Wenn ich eines noch sagen darf, auch wenn es vielleicht ein bisschen zynisch ist, ich werde mir auch in 10, 20 Jahren, wie lange es auch dauert, den Film drüber angucken. Weil ich irgendwie überzeugt bin, dass das mit James Cameron und Ridley Scott irgendwie für 500 Millionen Dollar da ein 1 zu 1 Modell vom World Trade Center noch mal in die Gesamtsacken lässt.
Hast du gestern Harald Schmidt gesehen oder was? Das mag jetzt zynisch klingen, aber was macht eigentlich der DAX? Manu, einen schönen Abend noch. Ja, danke. Chaosradio 65. Freiheit im Zeichen des Terrors ist unser Thema und wir haben eine Liste mit Musik, die in den USA nicht gespielt wird. Und weil sie in den USA nicht gespielt wird und wir ja Webradio unter anderem auch hier machen, spielen wir sie jetzt.
Fuck you, I won't do what you're telling me.
Chaosradio 65 auf Fritz und Sicherheit im Zeichen des Terrors, insbesondere Datensicherheit ist unser Thema und mitreden könnt ihr unter 0331 7097 110 und da hat auch Ecki angerufen und der hat unglaublich Sitzfleisch. Entschuldigung an dieser Stelle, dass du so lang warten musstest. Du bist für Telefonüberwachung.
Na, du hast mir vorhin gesagt, ihr müsst jetzt noch einmal Musik spielen.
Niemand sagt, dass wir es müssen, dass wir es müssen. Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass sowas wie der Freie Wille existiert. Das ist ja auch noch strittig. Das haben wir uns so ausgesucht.
Es gab schon mal Moderatoren, die haben davon abgesehen, Nachrichten zu senden, nur weil noch ein Hörer dran war. Aber lassen wir das. Was zahlt euch die Telekom dafür, dass ich hier eine Dreiviertelstunde drinnen hänge?
Wollt ihr mich beschweren oder willst mit uns reden?
Gut, ich rede jetzt mit euch. Also gut, ich bin in der DDR aufgewachsen und da hatten wir einen totalen Überwachungsstaat.
Na ja, so halbwegs. Hatte auch nicht mal jeder Telefon.
Na gut, aber es hat sich niemand getraut, irgendwas zu sagen. Ich habe da nicht drunter gelitten. Sicher, jetzt kommen auch meine Zweifel. Also ich möchte diesen Staat auch nicht hochleben lassen. Aber wenn man eine Überwachung hat und da schließe ich jetzt nicht nur das Telefon ein, sondern alle möglichen Medien und Kommunikationswege, dann wird es kaum möglich sein, dass jemand Terror macht.
Wieso? Ich meine, wieso glaubst du, dass man irgendwie Telekommunikationsüberwachung irgendwie benötigt, um einen Terroranschlag durchzuführen? Kann ich mit Leuten am Park irgendwie zu verabreden, muss ich kein Stück Telefon, muss kein Brief schreiben, keine Einzige E-Mail. Und wenn ich irgendwie tatsächlich hingehe und irgendwie wirklich irgendwie ein kleines Team kommunizieren will, dann kann ich das tun, ohne dass mich irgendein Geheimdienst dabei erwischen kann.
Ja, aber die Überwachung ging weit drüber über die technischen Möglichkeiten.
Willst du wieder eine Viertelmillion irgendwie E-M's haben? Naja, ich meine, das ist die Alternative, oder?
Sicher nicht. Ich weiß ja, ob es einen Weg gibt, das mit demokratischen Mitteln durchzusetzen.
Guck dir einfach mal die Geheimdienstskandalen der letzten Jahre an und dann erklären wir irgendwie, dass irgendwie Geheimdienste demokratisch kontrollierbar sind. Das ist doch irgendwie lachhaft, oder?
Mag sein.
Na der BND schon. Also die benehmen sich so dilettantisch bis weinend, dass man so kontrollieren kann.
Naja, da schaffen sogar schon die Journalisten die zu kontrollieren, meinst du?
Ja meine Hoffnung ist nur, dass es irgendwie möglich ist. Überwachung ja bis ins letzte Detail, ohne dabei Missbrauch.
Aber ich glaube da, an der Stelle muss ich mal kurz das Bundesverfassungsgericht zitieren. Die haben 1984 in einem Urteil, wo es um die Volksführung ging, mal aus dem Recht sich überhaupt frei bewegen, frei zu äußern und sich auch frei politisch zu äußern, das Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung abgleitet. Weil sie gesagt haben, wenn jemand nicht mehr weiß, was andere über ihn wissen, dann wird er möglicherweise einfach bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr tun, weil er möglicherweise Konsequenzen befürchtet, ob die eintreten oder nicht. Aber einfach nur, dass Latente nicht wissen, was andere an wissen, dann werden bestimmte Leute nicht mehr über Politik diskutieren. Das heißt, das was du da vorschickst wird möglicherweise nicht Terrorismus, aber Demokratie unmöglich machen. Nämlich, die beruht nämlich darauf, dass wir frei denken, entscheiden und uns äußern können. Und auch mal politische Ideen diskutieren können, die vielleicht nicht mit dem übereinklang stehen, was gerade Herr Schröder oder Herr irgendwie Helmut Schröder oder Gerhard Kohl oder wie sie auch heute gerade heißen da singen.
Ganz kurz noch mal zu meiner Geschichte. Ich habe Anfang der 90er Jahre genauso gedacht, dort war absolut demokratiefreundlich und habe auch alle möglichen Überwachungen abgelehnt. Aber seit zwei Wochen sehe ich das wieder ein bisschen anders.
Wieso? Ich meine, glaubst du denn wirklich ernsthaft, dass Überwachung irgendwas gegen Terrorismus bringen würde? Also ganz ehrlich. Also mal so ganz praktisch runter irgendwie zu irgendwie da rennen noch irgendwie 50 Leute rum, die möglicherweise genau dasselbe nochmal wachen wollen oder irgendeinen anderen Anschlag. Glaubst du wirklich ernsthaft, dass sie mit Telefonüberwachung zu kriegen sein werden?
Wir reden nicht nur über Telefonüberwachung.
Na wovon denn noch?
Davon totaler Überwachung.
Na was soll denn das sein?
Ich meine, nenn mir beliebige Beispiele überwachen. Ich nenne dir beliebige Methoden, die zum Gehen und irgendwie ist es vollkommen klar, dass irgendwie die Leute, die solche Anschläge produzieren, irgendwie nicht so blöd sind, irgendwie dass sie von irgendwie normalen Methoden kriegen lassen.
Wenn die Überwachung nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern weltweit so ausgedehnt wäre wie in der DDR, dann hätten die einfach mal gewonnen.
Weil dann hätten wir hier irgendwie einen Regime, wo ich irgendwie sagen würde, dann gehe ich selber in den Untergrund. Weißt du, irgendwie dann haben die Talibans da wirklich gewonnen. So, weil dann haben wir uns tatsächlich ihrem Willen gebeugt. Dann haben wir tatsächlich genau diese Dinge, die jetzt angeblich verteidigt werden sollen, irgendwie geopfert, irgendwie nur weil sie irgendwie damit gedroht haben, noch ein paar Anschläge zu machen. Das ist dann nämlich genau der Punkt. Dann haben sie gewonnen.
Okay, der Weltfrieden wird nicht durch total Überwachung gesichert, sondern durch Politik. Der wird nicht durch Kriege der USA oder sonst beim wem gesichert, sondern durch vernünftige Politik. Und das kann noch viele 10, 20, 30 Jahre dauern.
Ja, aber wenn wir diese These, die du jetzt gerade geäußert hast, mal als gegeben sehen und uns dann fragen, wir haben diese Politik nicht, können wir dann daraus ableiten, weil im Moment haben wir nicht den Frieden, den wir gerne hätten, den diese Politik verursachen könnte. Und dann willst du also dieser Politik, die nicht in der Lage ist, den Frieden zu erstellen, willst du jetzt die Instrumente für den Überwachungsstaat in die Hand geben? Und dann glaubst du, wird alles gut? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Nein, davon wird es nicht gut, aber davor schützen wir uns erst mal.
Wer schützt sich da vor wem?
Also ich meine, was ist der Nutzen? Wir haben gerade festgestellt, es wird uns nichts helfen. Es hat keinerlei realistische Aussicht auf Erfolg. Es wird eine ganze Menge Leute dazu bringen, dass sie sich erst recht gegen diesen Staat wenden, weil sie tatsächlich genau das, was sie immer gedacht und behauptet haben, nämlich dass dieser Staat faschistische Tendenzen hat, irgendwie erfüllt sehen und dass dieser Staat tatsächlich in der Lage ist, irgendwie solche Dinge zu machen, die eigentlich mit totalitären Regimen verkoppelt werden, nämlich totale Überwachung. Und letzten Endes fühlt es irgendwie tatsächlich nur zu viel mehr Gewalt und nicht zu viel weniger Gewalt. Also insofern muss ich ehrlich sagen, irgendwie kann ich deine Argumentation nicht wirklich ganz nachvollziehen.
Na gut, in meiner Jugendzeit gab es keine Gewalt in meinem Staat.
Nicht? Also ich meine, dann hast du sie glaube ich nur nicht wahrgenommen. Also in dem Staat, den du da gerade erwähnt hast, der hat ein paar Leute sehr wohl gewaltsam weggesperrt. Und ich kenne da wirklich Geschichten, die ich nicht wirklich schön finde.
Finde ich auch nicht schön. Ich habe ja auch vorhin versucht darzustellen, ob man das kombinieren kann. Ob es möglich ist, diese Überwachung mit demokratischen Mitteln zu kombinieren.
Das hat sich doch in der Vergangenheit gezeigt, dass das ganz offensichtlich nicht funktioniert.
In welcher Vergangenheit?
In der Vergangenheit der BRD zum Beispiel, wenn du da mal zurück guckst.
Ja gut, die kenne ich nicht so genau. Na gut, ich würde das erdulden. Ich hätte auch nichts zu verbergen. Also ich würde mich dem stellen.
Ja und du hättest auch sicherlich nichts dagegen, wenn dann bestimmte deiner Tätigkeiten, Gedanken und sonst wie es dann der Gedankenpolizei vorgelegt werden und deinem jetzigen und zukünftigen potenziellen Arbeitgeber und etwa Mitmenschen vorgelegt werden und du vielleicht umgesiedelt wirst, wenn du in abweichenden Eigenschaften...
Nein, also so weit sind wir technisch noch nicht, dass wir Gedanken lesen können.
Du wolltest noch die total überwachen.
Ah, ok, ok, ok, nein, ich bin sogar schon so weit, dass man meine Gedanken lesen kann. Könnte man machen. Auch wenn sie schlecht werden. Dass das dann, ich glaub nicht, dass es negative Auswirkungen für mich hat, so schlecht sind meine Gedanken nicht.
Das Problem ist, dass das Problem...
Das bewerten aber andere.
Das ist eben das Problem, das bewerten andere und nicht nach den Maßstäben, die du, ich oder sonst wer anlegt.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel einer mache, ich würde deine Gedanken, die finde ich gerade echt... Also ich finde die nicht so toll, muss ich dir ehrlich sagen.
Und wo würdest du ihn hinsiedeln?
Ach, keine Ahnung, aber gibt es da nicht irgendwie noch irgendetwas dahinten?
Bayern oder Afghanistan? Bayern oder Afghanistan? Eins von beiden, wir überlegen.
Würde ich mich hinsiedeln lassen. Ich bin ein absoluter Pazifist und ich würde mich auch nach Bayern siedeln lassen.
Alles klar. Das ist mutig. Wir wünschen dir das trotzdem nicht, Eric.
Ich wünsche es mir auch nicht, aber ich würde es in Kauf nehmen.
Und wir danken für deinen Anruf.
Also so viel Mut muss man erstmal haben.
Zu sagen, ich gebe meine jegliche Privatheit auf.
Ja, und dass er sich sogar bereit wäre, nach Bayern umsiedeln zu lassen.
Vielleicht ist er kein Kiffer.
Na, das ist glaube ich nicht so sehr der Punkt. Nicht? Nee.
Wieso?
Also ich meine, das ist schon ein fortgeschrittener Maß. Okay, ich meine, das ist vielleicht auch ein Bedürfnis des Menschen, Macht an andere abzugeben oder sagen wir, also verstehst du, das ist ein bisschen dieses so O-Obrigkeit, nimm mich Schäfchen doch in deine Dings da. Das ist natürlich schön einfach, ne? Aber das hatten wir auch schon mal.
Hatten wir das?
Naja, ich meine so starke Führung und so.
Ach so, ja klar, nee, das hatten wir schon mal.
Das hatten wir schon mal ausprobiert.
Entschuldigung, jetzt haben wir ja dann auch alle unseren Schillen, nicht wahr?
Jetzt haben wir alle unseren Schillen. Ja, der will ja auch zum Bundestagswahlland.
Ich hab schon diverse Anfragen wegen politischem Asyl von Hamburgern bekommen.
Das sind bestimmt irgendwelche Kriminellen und Drogenhändler. Ansonsten würden sie ja gar nicht aus Hamburg weg wollen.
Genau.
Fragen wir mal Daniel, ob er noch dran ist.
Was lese ich hier? Daniel Schillig hat die Einführung einer Gedankenpolizei für die Assoziation Werder.
Daniel bist du noch dran? Bist du nicht? Schade.
Ich bin. Also als erstes fand ich es sehr witzig, was mein Vorwiener gerade so gesagt hat. Es ist so komisch jetzt zu sprechen, weil man hört den Hintergrund nicht mehr.
Achso, warte. Ich mach Geräusche, damit du den Hintergrund hörst.
Soll ich nochmal die, wollen wir nochmal die?
Nee, ich mach mal leichte Musik, mal gucken, ob du dann noch zu verstehen bist Sven, ok? Die CD läuft doch gar nicht.
Scheiße.
Ja, also ich kann nur eins sagen, ich habe erst seit Kurzem, oder im Prinzip erst seit dem ich am Telefon bin, die ganze Diskussion verfolgt. Ich habe mir vorher im Internet mal ein paar Themen angeguckt und habe mich eigentlich spontan dazu berufen, gefühlt mal anzurufen und möchte dazu nur eins sagen, wem hat das alles genützt? Und weitestgehend bin ich seit dem 11. September bei mir Programme einfallen zu lassen, um bestimmte E-Mails an bestimmte Leute von mir zu verschlüsseln, um dem Ganzen bestreben, was jetzt, naja, was jetzt da liegt oder was jetzt kommt, entgegen zu rücken, weil mich das einfach mal aufregt. Es regt mich einfach mal auf. Diese ganze Diskussion um Sicherheit und Pippa-Pro und Faxen-Kram ist einfach mal zum kotzen. Und naja, was soll ich groß sagen, ich will mich nicht überwachen lassen. Ich bin genauso wie mein Vorredner Bürger der ehemaligen DDR und ich habe davon absolut die Schnauze voll. Und wenn jemand der Meinung ist, er muss mich überwachen, dann soll er es tun. Aber bitte schön, soll er es professionell tun.
Also so, dass du es nicht mitkriegst?
Genau.
Oder derjenige soll sich die Haare zerraufen, um meinen E-Mail-Verkehr zu überwachen. Also entschuldigt bitte, ich kann das alles nicht mehr nachvollziehen. Dieser ganze Bamburium, ich meine, was haben die Amis sich denn erhofft?
Die Amis jetzt sich erhofft?
Das sind ja nicht nur die Amis, das ist ja auch unser Innenminister.
Entschuldigung mal, ein Herr Schili, der die 68er verteidigt hat und sich jetzt hinstellt, er möchte gerne einen Daumenabdruck oder Fingerabdruck oder wie auch immer an seinem Personalausweis haben. Entschuldigung mal bitte, wo sind wir denn hier? Also ich verstehe das alles nicht mehr, also ich meine, gut, ich bin selber kein 68er, mein Gott, als 68er war ich ja alt.
Man muss dazu aber auch sagen, dass der Herr Schili schon damals ein relativ distanziertes Verhältnis zu sein, Mandanten hatte, auch wenn es seiner Karriere nicht direkt abträglich war, was er da getan hat.
Letztlich hat er damals ja auch die verteidigt, die den Rechtsstaat bekämpft haben und jetzt bekämpft er ihn selber weiter.
Ja, aber man muss sozusagen bei der Rolle des Innenministers, jetzt zwar unabhängig, ob der heute Schili oder Zimmermann noch wie immer heißt, muss man auch eines sehen, nämlich diese Rolle hat eine bestimmte Definition, das ist wie so ein Schauspiel und die ist tatsächlich festgeschrieben. Und die Rolle des Innenministers ist nicht in letzter Linie für sozusagen die innere Sicherheit zu sorgen, weil das ist sozusagen naives Gedanken, was man in den 50er Jahren schon mit erfangen hat, sondern es geht darum, das muss man sich auf der Zuge zergehen lassen, das Sicherheitsgefühl des Bürgers zu adressieren. Das heißt, es geht darum, dass die Leute den Eindruck haben, wenn irgendwas Schlimmes passiert, dass der Staat irgendwie die Möglichkeit hat oder die Möglichkeit ergriff, irgendwie dafür zu sorgen, dass alles gut wird. Und wenn in deiner Straße zweitmal am Tag ein Bullenwagen rumfährt, dann geht es nicht darum, dass der dadurch verhindert, dass da eingebrochen wird, weil es leuchtet.
Das ist bei mir der Fall und trotzdem haben sie mir das Auto aufgebrochen.
Aber die Leute denken halt, oh ja, die Polizei ist da, es ist alles schön und gut. Und das ist natürlich sozusagen ein bisschen fatal, weil genau in diese Lücke stößt ja der Schül rein mit seinen Reihen auf innere Sicherheit und dadurch letztendlich Faschistuinparolen. Natürlich waren wir die Totalen. Ja natürlich, aber das ist eben genau, dass du kannst bei Sicherheit immer noch ein Stück draufgehen, weil es gibt keine Sicherheit.
Das ist total Quatsch.
Ich sage darum haben wir in Brandenburg auch Schönbohm jetzt als Innenminister.
Ja, er ist in Berlin sogar freiwillig aus Berlin weggegangen. Nachdem er eigentlich hätte zurücktreten müssen.
Das konnte dem Mann nicht passieren, also Entschuldigung bitte. Mein kurzes Statement dazu ist Überwachung nein. Überwachung ist auch nicht dienlich dazu, solche Anschläge zu verhindern. Weil hinter solchen Anschlägen da stecken mentale Einstellungen, die wir hier als Mitteuropäer schlecht nachvollziehen können. Da liegt die Sache ganz woanders begründet. Und wer eben der Meinung ist, er muss jetzt irgendeinem Jumbo-Pilot mal eine Knarre an den Kopf halten und sich selbst da irgendwo hinfliegen, das können wir hier nicht so richtig nachvollziehen.
Hättest du trotzdem eine Idee, wie man sowas für die Zukunft verhindern kann?
Ja, man müsste mal aufeinander zugehen und man müsste mal die Millionen oder die Milliarden, die im Jahr für irgendwelche Rüstungsmaßnahmen ausgegeben werden, mal darin investieren, bestimmte Leute mal über den Inhalt ihrer Religion aufzuklären. Und das betrifft nicht nur Leute, die überhaupt an eine gewisse Religion glauben. Denn ich glaube, der Grundkonsens einer jeden Religion ist, du sollst deinen Nächsten lieben. Und wenn man das in alle Völker hineinbekommt, ich glaube, dann ist der Weltweitaus mehr geholfen als mit irgendwelchen Raketenabwehrprogrammen oder sonstiges.
Eine Alphabetisierungskampagne wäre auf jeden Fall mit Sicherheit billiger als Raketenabwehrprogramme.
Genau, genau. Na ja, mein Gott, was wollen wir jetzt hier reden? Wir wissen doch alle, worum es geht. Habt ihr letzten Sonnabend John F. K gesehen, der Lister, womit geht? Geld. Es ist nur Geld, worum es geht.
Rüstungsgeld.
Ja, Blutgeld.
Sven, bevor wir uns noch weiter eschaufieren, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Kleine Musik von der Liste. Gut. Ich sag's nochmal für die, die sich jetzt erst zugeschaltet haben. Chaosradio 65 auf Fritz. Freiheit im Zeichen des Terrors ist so unser wages Thema. Und wir haben eine Liste mit Musik, die in den USA nicht im Radio gespielt werden soll. Also liebe Leute, die hier gerade in den USA zuhört, vielleicht über Internet. Wir haben es jetzt. Also wir spielen es jetzt quasi. Spielts doch mal. Was fasil ich denn hier die ganze Zeit?
Dann 89, 8.
Eine nach halb eins.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Heute Nacht Nebel, bei Temperaturen zwischen 9 und 7 Grad. Morgen wolkig Regen, maximal 18 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit gesehen.
Die NATO und Russland wollen im Kampf gegen den Terrorismus noch enger als bisher zusammenarbeiten. Das sagte Russlands Verteidigungsminister Ivanov nach einem Treffen mit seinem NATO-Kollegen in Brüssel. Er machte allerdings auch deutlich, dass russische Truppen nicht für eine Militäraktion gegen Afghanistan zur Verfügung stünden. Der Parteichef der Grünen, Kuhn, hat den Einsatz von Bodentruppen der Bundeswehr im Ausland unter bestimmten Umständen nicht ausgeschlossen. Seine Partei würde einen solchen Einsatz zustimmen, wenn damit eine politische Lösung gewährleistet sei, sagte Kuhn in der ARD. Bund und Länder sind sich einig, das Bankgeheimnis zu lockern, um den Terrorismus zu bekämpfen. Das sagte Bundeskanzler Schröder nach einem Treffen mit den Regierungschefs der Länder. Außerdem wurde vorgeschlagen, die Rastafanung bundesweit zu nutzen und einen unbeschränkten Austausch von Polizeidaten zu ermöglichen. Mehrere Friedens- und Literaturen-Mobilpreisträger haben sich gegen einen Krieg in Afghanistan ausgesprochen. Im ARD-Magazin Monitor warnten sie vor einer Spirale der Gewalt. Zu Wort meldeten sich unter anderem der südafrikanische Bischof Desmond Tutu, der Schriftsteller Günter Gras und der Theaterregisseur Dario Faux. Und zum Sport in der Fußball-Champions-Liga gab es am Abend folgende Ergebnisse. Schalke 04 unterlag Real Mallorca mit 0 zu 1 und Boa Vista Porto schlug Borussia Dortmund 2 zu 1.
Boa Vista Kühne, vielen Dank, Gesine. 0 Uhr 3 und 30.
Was?
Lass uns da mal die Töne...
Chaosradio 65 auf Fritz, sicher, nee, was haben wir denn wieder frei im Zeichen des Terrors? Das ist unser Thema heute Abend unter 0331, 77, 91, 20, 0 können wir noch 20 Minuten miteinander reden. Und jetzt reden wir mit Gundel, hallo Gundel.
Gundel?
Hallo?
Hallo? Ja, wunderbar. Wir hören dich. Hörst du uns?
Ich höre euch auch. Ja, ich habe eine Anekdote mit meinem Reisepass erlebt in diesem Jahr, der zehn Jahre abgelaufen ist oder war.
Moment, der ist seit zehn Jahren...
Nein, den hatte ich vor zehn Jahren beantragt. Weil ich auch ehemalige DDR-Bürgerin war und hatte den dann beantragt und das lief auch alles ganz gut. 1992 hatten wir bei uns im Haus einen Einbruch und da wurde dieser Reisepass gestohlen. Warum? Ich bekam den dann aber nach circa vier Wochen zurück über die Meldestelle und hatte aber zwischenzeitlich, weil ich nach USA reisen musste dienstlich, hatte ich einen neuen Reisepass beantragt. Bekam meinen alten dann aber wie gesagt über die Meldestelle zurück und hab den neuen überhaupt nie abgeholt. So, jetzt war nach zehn Jahren, ich bin in dieser Zeit circa 15 bis 17 mal nach USA eingereist, ausgereist in andere Länder in der Welt. Es ist also ohne Probleme nie irgendwas passiert. Ich möchte meinen neuen Reisepass beantragen. Man schaut in die Akten und sagt, das geht überhaupt nicht. Sie haben einen Reisepass, der gültig ist. Und dieser Reisepass, den Sie mir hier vorliegen, der steht auf der Fahndungsliste. Ja, und wirklich in arabische Länder, nach Amerika eingereist, ausgereist, in Frankfurt auf dem Flughafen, in München auf dem Flughafen, egal wo. Ich bin nie angesprochen worden, dass irgendwas nicht funktionieren sollte, ohne Probleme.
Das ist interessant, ich hatte mal komplett anders gelagert das Problem. Und zwar vielmehr oft, dass ich immer, wenn ich irgendwelche Landgrenzen überquerte, dass mein Reisepass dann bei der Passkontrolle immer so für 10 Minuten, viertel Stunde irgendwie dann noch ins Hinterzimmer getragen wurde. Und dann irgendwann nach einer tschechischen Grenze, als noch irgendwie alles leer war und ich da der Einzelne in der Grenze war, denen zugegeben hat, sagen sie, gut, dass man sie sehen kann, ich bin irgendwie ein harmloser Bürger und mich würde das jetzt einfach mal interessieren, wieso sind sie einfach irgendwie hier so der ungefähr 20. Zwölender, der mit meinem Reisepass nach hinten verschwindet. Und dann meint er, also ganz trockene, also an ihrer Stelle würde ich mir einfach mal einen Reisepass holen, weil irgendwie ihrer ist nur eine Buchstabenstelle von einer Serie entfernt, die in einer Meldestelle geklaut wurde.
Ja, aber die andere Geschichte, also es dauerte dann auch wirklich circa anderthalb Stunden auf der Meldestelle, bis das alles geklärt war. Ich sollte tatsächlich keinen neuen Reisepass bekommen und ich nachweisen konnte, dass ich überhaupt keinen anderen besitze.
Wie weiß man denn so was nach?
Ja, ich hab versichert, hab dann eidesstattlich versichert, dass ich keinen anderen habe. Und witzig war dann...
Aber man muss doch unterschreiben, wenn man seinen Reisepass abholt oder nicht?
Ja, also es war irgendwie völlig konfus. Und ich bekam dann, ich glaube zwei oder drei Tage später, bekam ich dann in Nachricht, dass das alles in Ordnung wäre. Und ja, ich könnte jetzt meinen, der neue Reisepass würde jetzt ausgestellt werden. Und das würde alles laufen und sie entschuldigen sich und ja.
Und hätte ein Fußabdruck in einem Reisepass geholfen?
Na, ich denke eher nicht. Denn es heißt ja auch so, dass dieser Reisepass, dass der wirklich so sicher sein soll und dass man da alle möglichen Dinge kontrollieren kann. Der wird da durchgezogen und die Nummern werden kontrolliert. Aber wie gesagt, wenn der auf der Fahndungsliste tatsächlich gestanden hat...
Sie sind ja noch nicht mehr in der Lage ordentlich zu fahnden.
Also dann frage ich mich, was in den 10 Jahren in Deutschland hier passiert ist.
Ich hoffe, ich bin doch nicht so genau wissend jetzt.
Ja, aber irgendwas werden die mit dem Geld gemacht haben. Das ist eine interessante Frage. Ja, aber so ist das. Nee, ich meine, das ist bei Geheimdiensten ja auch so ein Problem. Ich meine, das ist dann halt geheim, aber ist auf jeden Fall ein Hinweis, den wir nachgeben werden.
Also ich denke, das ist doch wirklich eine nette Anekdote zu diesem Thema.
In der Tat, ja. Vielen Dank und gute Nacht.
Gerne.
So, Freunde der Lichtspielkunst. Ich lese jetzt gerade mal eine frische Meldung von Associated Press vor.
Auch nicht wieder schon wieder Realität.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung. Die Rede des amerikanischen Präsidenten George W. Bush vor dem US-Kongress aus Anlass der Terroranschläge in New York und Washington wird als Buch erscheinen. Außer der Rede wird es auch eine Chronologie der Ereignisse zwischen dem 11. und 20. September enthalten, 48 Seiten umfassen und in einer ersten Auflage von 100.000 Stück erscheinen.
Ob denn ein Copyright auch der Boris Willis drin steht?
Erzähl noch mal die Geschichte für die, die später zugeschaltet haben.
Neulich beim Filmgucken abends oft, dass etliche Passagen der Rede des amerikanischen Präsidenten zu den tragischen Ereignissen in New York wortwörtliche Zitate aus einer Ansprache waren, die Boris Willis als Evil General in dem Film Belagungszustand auf Englisch The Siege gehalten hat, kurz bevor irgendwie den Ausnahmezustand in New York ausruft, das Militär einretten lässt und alle Araber interniert. Das fand ich schon ein bisschen bedenklich. Make no mistake, we got a job to do, no matter what the price.
Das heißt doch, dass es das schon als Buch gibt?
Zumindest scheinen sie für solche Zwecke Drehbücher fertig vorliegen zu haben. Zumindest scheint der Risake-Kreislauf relativ kurz zu sein.
Es ist so herrlich.
Christian.
Ja, also meine Meinung ist jetzt, dass jetzt, was den ganzen Abend schon besprochen wird, mit der inneren Sicherheit, dass es doch eigentlich nur dazu da ist, um die augenblickliche Gefahr zu unterbinden. Und dass es ja nicht die Lösung ist, um den Terrorismus zu besiegen. Und die Gefahr ist ja dann immer vorhanden, dass trotzdem irgendwie eine Bombe sag ich mal hochgeht, indem doch irgendeine Sache übersehen wird und dann irgendwie eine schlimme Sache passiert. Und deshalb bin ich der Auffassung, dass im Prinzip die ganzen Islamregionen da, dass da auch ein bisschen gelockert werden muss. Dass vielleicht, sag mal, die USA und Europa, dass die vielleicht dafür sorgen, dass dort überall eine Demokratie eingeführt wird. Das haben die USA versucht, ja. Naja, man müsste die Leute da unten da zu zwingen. Also ich hab da zum Beispiel mal ein paar Sachen so im Fernsehen gesehen, dass zum Beispiel so ein Theologe hat zum Beispiel gesagt, dass jetzt das, was im Koran drin steht, also der ganze Islam da unten, das jetzt sich nicht so lockern wird, so wie zum Beispiel bei den Christen ist. Die haben ja immer über das halt die eine oder andere Sache dann doch ein bisschen lockrei sehen, ja. Und dass das bei den Menschen da unten so ist, dass sie eher doch wieder sogar noch zu den, also eher zu den Herzenssachen zurückfinden. Also dass da auf jeden Fall irgendwie eine Lockung ist, in der sich zum Beispiel das Frauen eben, wie die Frauen so, sag mal, unterbunden wären, indem sie da immer mit so ein Klamotten da rumrennen müssen und...
Ja Moment, aber was du da sagst, das stimmt ja insofern nicht ganz, als dass sie bei den Christen ja jetzt auch, zumindest bei Bush und so fort, das ist ja jetzt auch altes Testament und das glaubten wir ja im Christentum auch schon überwunden zu haben.
Ja und vor allen Dingen...
Nee, ich meine, der Islam der ist doch... War jetzt eine Frage an Ihnen. Die Frage war, ob das sozusagen so, ob man das wirklich so sagen kann, dass das Christentum sich sozusagen entspannt hat.
Ja, na also das muss ich sagen, dass ja, also ich persönlich denke jetzt, also ich glaube jetzt nicht an Gott oder so eine höhere Macht und ich persönlich denke, dass alle, sag ich mal, Religionen für mich irgendwo auch was mit einer Sekte zu tun haben. Ja, bloß, als meine persönliche Meinung. Bloß man muss da eben unterscheiden zwischen den Sekten, die im Prinzip den Menschen scharen können und zwischen den Religionen, die gute Menschen hervorholen sollen. Und ich denke mal, dass das Christentum doch immer, ich sag mal, ein bisschen wandeln konnte. Zum Beispiel ganz früher war es noch so mit den Hexenverbrennungen oder auch die Meinungsgegenüber, zum Beispiel Schwulen, die wird ja auch immer mehr gelockert. Und ich denke mal, dass sich das Christentum über die Zeit, die hängt schon mal ein bisschen hinterher, aber sich schon die modernen Menschen so anpassen. Und demzufolge finde ich das so gut, wenn du dir, sag mal, vielen Menschen hilfst, die an Gott glauben und dadurch halt eben ihre Lebenskraft gewinnen, kann ich das nur gut heißen. Aber eben im Islam, wo die Frauen eben, sag ich mal, so dermaßen unterdrückt wären, muss ich sagen, dass ich nicht denke, dass das eine Religion ist, die, naja, sag ich mal, für das Wohl der Menschheit förderlich ist. Und ich denke auch, gerade jetzt bei der Form des Terrorismus wie es jetzt in den USA gezeigt worden ist, dass die eben ihr Leben aufgeben, also ihr Leben dafür opfern. Und machen sie ja nicht unbedingt nur aus Ideologie, sondern machen sie ja, weil sie glauben, dass sie denn in den Paradies kommen, als Hell sozusagen. Und ich denke mal, dass das eben ganz falsche Grundwerte vielleicht sind, die da vermittelt werden. Und dass man da eben anfangen muss, die Leute da ein bisschen zu liberalisieren, und den Leuten zu zeigen, es gibt auch andere Wege. Und vor allen Dingen in der jungen Generation. Den Kindern, die oft demokratisch in der Schule und über andere Organe zu erziehen, damit die wissen, es gibt auch noch alle andere Lebensarten.
Ich will jetzt, dir neigt, was ganz Brutales dazu zu sagen. Weil du hast da gerade so eine religiöse Sichtweise dargestellt, und die hat man auch schon an andere Stellen gehört und gelesen. Aber wenn du dir mal die Lebenssituation von Leuten in Pakistan und Afghanistan anguckst, dann ist der Tod für die möglicherweise tatsächlich der angenehmere Zustand, als das Leben irgendwie, wo sie täglich von entweder den Israelis massakriert werden oder den Hungertod sterben. Das hat sicherlich, glaube ich, schon auch was mit Lebensumständen zu tun und nicht nur mit Religionen. Bevor so eine Religion greifen kann.
Es gibt da, wie im Christentum, unterschiedliche extreme Störungen. Es gibt auch Leute, die da sehr entspannter und weltliche Einstellungen haben und sich trotzdem dem Islam zu gehörig fühlen. Es ist so, als würde man sagen, das ist Christentum. Wie im Christentum gibt es genauso viele durchgeknallte, wie im Islam, nur dass die gerade keine Flugzeuge und irgendwelche Hochhäuser fliegen. Jede Religion hat halt zu gewissen Zeit in ihrer terroristischen Periode irgendwie das Christentum, hat nun zum Glück schon ein paar hundert Jahre hinter sich. Aber das werden wir halt irgendwie mit allen Religionen, die zumindest irgendwie in gewisser Art und Weise missionarisch tätig sind, missionarisch und machtmäßig tätig sind, irgendwie erleben. Also insofern bringt das jetzt wenigstens das nun auf den Islam an sich zu schieben. Also das halte ich für Unsinn.
Ja, naja, aber ich sage ja nicht, dass der Islam sozusagen abgeschafft werden soll. Ich bin ja nur der Meinung, dass es sozusagen kontrolliert werden soll.
Wer soll denn kontrollieren? Ich meine, das ist halt eine Religion. Und Religionen können wie gesagt auch mal extreme Züge annehmen. Das ist gerade mal der Fall. Und da muss man halt irgendwie Wege und Mittel finden, damit umzugehen.
Aber man muss sich fragen, wieso soll diese Züge annehmen? Und das ist eben deswegen, weil es schon so stark verstrickt ist, dass die neuen Kinder, die geboren werden, 5 Jahre alt, die bekommen das ganze Leben von ihren Eltern, von ihrem Umfeld mit. So hier in Deutschland ein 5 Jahre altes Kind, hat ja auch noch Kontakt zu Nicht-Christen, also hat die ganze Palette so. Und das ist da nicht mehr gegeben.
Das kommt drauf an, wo es aufwächst, nehme ich an.
Na, ich denke schon, dass da, sag ich mal, Saudi-Arabien und die ganzen Länder da unten, dass das da nicht alles so frei ist. Also wenn man das so im Fernsehen sieht, also das kommt mir nicht so vor, als wenn die da alles so...
Jeder hat das Recht so zu leben, wie er es irgendwie für gut hält.
Genau, genau, genau, genau, in der Meinung bin ich ja auch.
Letzterweise ist es alles eine Frage, was ist die Definition von normal? Und normal ist irgendwie, was der größere Teil der Leute in einer Gesellschaft als normal erachtet. Leider ist es in Deutschland auch nicht unbedingt das, was ich toll finde. Und insofern, jetzt da über den Islam oder die Gesellschaften da unten als Ursache herzuzielen, halt ich finde ziemlich einen Unsinn. Es gibt im Christentum genügend Sekten, die, wenn sie die Gelegenheit dazu hätten, ähnlich grausame Dinge tun würden. Wenn du dir zum Beispiel mal die christlichen Milizen in USA anguckst, die da irgendwie losgehen, und Timothy McVeigh war da sicherlich nur irgendwie die Spitze des Eisberges, also insofern ist es irgendwie einigermaßen Unsinn, solche Argumente anzufinden.
Ja, aber du hast ja gerade gesagt, dass die Leute da unten im Islam noch die Möglichkeit haben, sich frei zu entwickeln. Jeder Mensch hat das Recht, sich sozusagen frei zu entwickeln.
Wenn es die westliche Anschauung sein sollte, ich meine zum Beispiel in Japan, was man ja nur als fast zivilisierte Gesellschaft ansehen könnte, gibt es da auch schon ganz andere Ansichten darüber. In China gibt es da auch wieder ganz andere Ansichten dazu. Insofern unsere Ansicht von irgendwie, was nun gut und richtig ist, um diese Weltgegner zu exportieren, ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen vermessen. Aber der italienische Ministerpräsident ist da sicherlich der Meinung, dass man das irgendwie tun könnte.
Aber ich denke mal, wenn ich als deutscher Kind geboren werde, habe ich doch die Möglichkeit, mich für Christentum zu entscheiden, nicht für das Islam zu entscheiden. Und wenn ich jetzt im Islam, durch die tiefen Regionen geboren werde, dann habe ich doch keine freie Möglichkeit, mich für euch noch als Christentum entscheiden.
Der gravierende Unterschied an der Stelle ist, dass du, wenn du in den Islam hineingeboren wirst, oder in ein islamistisches Land hineingeboren wirst, du in ein Land hineingeboren wirst, in dem es keine Sekularisierung gibt, also keine Trennung von Staat und Religion. Das ist das Problem. Wenn du als deutsches Kind geboren wirst, dann wirst du auch in eine Gesellschaftsordnung hineingeboren, gegen die du dich nicht wehren kannst. Das ist genau dasselbe, wenn du in den Islam hineingeboren bist. Nur, dass da die Gesellschaftsordnung eben religiös motiviert ist, und nicht wirtschaftlich motiviert ist, wie es bei uns jetzt der Fall ist. Und mit diesen Worten entlasse ich dich, Christian. Wir haben noch jemanden in der Leitung und noch ein paar Minuten Zeit. Ich danke dir, Tschüss. So, Steffen. Steffen? Steffen, du hast das letzte Wort. Ihr wollt noch eine Musik hören? Ja, machen wir doch zum Schluss. Oder wollt ihr noch eine Musik hören?
Lass uns doch mal mit dem Mann reden.
Erstmal mit Steffen und dann hören wir noch eine Musik. Fuchtet man nicht rum, Jungs. Steffen, bitte.
Ja, ich hab von eurem Gedanken, der mehrmals erwähnt worden ist, mich ziemlich entsetzt, und zwar mit der Sicherheitstür in dem Cockpit. Mir ist der Sinn und Zweck dieser Tür nicht ganz klar. Ich sag's mal so, normalerweise gibt's hier ein Jahr lang Streit über den finalen Rettungsschuss. Und hier entscheidet bei so einer Geisennahme der Flugkapitän über mein Leben, das heißt über das andere Leben. Das ist mir nicht klar.
Das tut der Flugkapitän momentan auch. Der Flugkapitän ist laut Gesetz, solange das Flugzeug sich in der Luft befindet, für Leib und lebende Passagiere zuständig und hat auch tatsächlich die Möglichkeit und das Recht, Gewaltmaßnahmen zu ergreifen und das Leben der Passagiere zu sichern. Und wenn er tatsächlich der Meinung ist, dass du irgendwie, also dass die Jungs da hinten in der Kabine gerade mal irgendwie 20 Leute mit den Messern umbringen können, damit er nicht in Hochhaus fliegen muss, dann ist es ein gutes Recht. Wenn er es nicht gefällt, steigst du nicht in den Flugzeug. Das ist halt irgendwie, guck, einfach ins Luftfahrt gesetzt, da steht genau das drin. Das ist irgendwie genau das selbe mit Schiffen. Wenn du auf dem Schiff bist, hat der Kapitän das tatsächliche absolute Hochheitsrecht auf diesem Schiff. Und wenn er der Meinung ist, dass du stößt und erschossen werden musst, dann hat er das Recht dazu. Was sollst du dagegen tun? Ich meine, mach kurz die Abwägung. Willst du irgendwie, dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, dass hinten ein Pasturdessen nicht drauf gehen müssen, dass die Jungs im Flugzeug in den Hochhaus fliegen können?
Woher will er denn, dass er jemanden wiffen, dass der ins Hochhaus fliegt?
Ich meine, die Frage ist, wie willst du es ausschließen? Wenn heutzutage ein Flugzeug entführt wird, wirst du davon ausgehen, dass das der Fall ist? Also ist es die einfachste Möglichkeit zu verhindern, dass die in Führerkontrolle übers Flugzeug gewinnen?
Ich meine, ich will mal was ganz anderes sagen. Du hast selber gerade gesagt, das ist eine neue Dimension. Und das ist es ganz sicherlich, wenn man bisher als Passagier davon ausgehen konnte, bei einer Flugzeugentführung, dass man in Anführungszeichen nur als Geisel zur Freipressung von Gefangenen, Geldbeträgen oder was auch immer diente, so muss man jetzt halt im Zeitzahl davon ausgehen, dass die Reiserichtung hoch aus oder was auch immer geht. Und entsprechend muss man sich so verhalten. Das heißt, ich glaube schon, dass auch sozusagen die Terroristen mit dieser neuen Dimension eine Option verloren haben, nämlich darauf zu spekulieren, dass die Passagiere sich schön ruhig verhalten, in der Annahme, sie würden ja nur entführt werden. Das ist jetzt halt nicht mehr zwangsläufig anzunehmen. Und damit will ich nicht gutheißen, dass da jetzt eine verriegelte Tür ist, anstelle von anderen Maßnahmen vielleicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ich finde das irgendwie ganz sinnvoll.
Ja, das ist vielleicht ganz sinnvoll, aber das ist sicherlich nicht sinnvoll als einzigste Maßnahme.
Na gut, sicherlich nicht als einzigste Maßnahme. Also hier ist eine sehr einfache Maßnahme, um die Katastrophen dieser Größenordnung zu verhindern. Übrigens finde ich sowieso, dass irgendwie die Diskussion und diese ganzen Überwachungsmaßnahmen geht halt ziemlich daran vorbei, dass man eigentlich eine ganze Menge Maßnahmen ergreifen könnte, um die grundlegende technische Sicherheit dieser Gesellschaft ein bisschen zu verbessern. Ja, aber das ist eh nicht ausschließlich. Nein, davon rede ich auch nicht. Aber es wird halt immer wieder gerne mit diesem nicht ausschließlich Argument in den Hintergrund gedrängt und dann schlicht und ergreifend vergessen. Der Punkt ist halt einfach, dass wir in einer Gesellschaft leben, die an vielen Stellen technologische Hochrisiko-Probleme hat, die sich prima für terroristische Anschläge nutzen lassen. Und wenn man irgendwie mal anfängt, diese Risiken irgendwie ein bisschen abzubauen, dann wird diese Gesellschaft auch ein Stück sicherer, ohne dass da für irgendjemand überwacht werden muss.
Steffen, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf und gute Nacht. Das war Chaosradio 65. Chaosradio 66 gibt's in exakt vier Wochen. Also Mittwoch in vier Wochen. Und wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ist das sogar der 23. Denkt doch mal mit, keine Kalenderauftasche. Ja, in exakt vier Wochen, und wenn das der 23. ist, dann freuen wir uns sogar darüber. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Es verabschieden sich im Studio Holger Klein. Das ist mein Name, ansonsten waren noch da Frank, Andreas und Andy.
Und ansonsten wünschen wir uns Frieden auf Erden und eine gute Gesellung für jedermann.
Frieden und ein Wohlgefallen, war da nicht das Wohlgefallen.
Und übrigens ist das der 24.
Holger.
Ich hab doch gesagt, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ich hab das jetzt versucht im Kopf zu rechnen.
Nächstes Chaosradio am 24. Oktober und das Thema, da denken wir uns noch was zu ausbreiten. Dann guckt ihr auf www.ccc.de oder auf chaosradio.ccc.de und da gibt es auch irgendwo ein Chaos Update Mailing Listing, da wo ihr euch eintragen lasst einen ganz schönen Abend.
Tschüss.
Ein Gemeinschaftsprogramm von ORB und SFB produziert in Babelsberg.